so you know that the lab leak story that
kovid came from a lab apparently it's
true U.S department of energy says uh
basically that is the most likely case
though they're saying it was with low
confidence it seems yeah covid likely
leaked from a lab in China I suppose the
question is why are they now admitting
it in the government and and perhaps it
could be I don't know Casas belly the
U.S just had a spy balloon fly overhead
there may be a conflict with China
coming and the U.S now wants to hear
public support for why there may be a
war and it actually is quite perfect I
think the reality is Dr fauci gave
funding to an organization which then
did gain of function research at the
virus Factory in Wuhan that's what
Sheamus Coughlin called it it was good
joke Sheamus the virus Factory and then
they didn't want to admit it but we'll
see we don't know Woody Harrelson
however on Saturday Night Live was uh he
made a really funny joke about how big
Pharma no I'm sorry he said he said the
cartels bought up all the meat and all
the politicians and locked everyone in
their homes and they could only leave if
they did the cartels drugs over and over
and over over again he's getting a lot
of heat for that
so we'll talk about that I guess it's a
interesting day and Scott Adams is
apparently getting canceled from
everything Dilbert his comic is being
canceled because he was commenting on a
poll from Rasmussen that said 26 of
black people who were polled disagreed
with the statement it's okay to be white
and then he commented on that saying you
should stay away from these people among
other things but we'll get into the into
the details of what he said to get and
get specific with it because I'm sure
people are both uh people on all sides
are offended by what's happening before
we get started my friends head over to
timcast.com click the join us button and
become a member because we're gonna have
a members only show coming up around 10
10 p.m tonight so when this show wraps
up live it goes from 8 to 10 we then set
up the Live members only portion at
timcast.com which will then get archived
and be available for you to watch
whenever you want but
now you can also watch live plus we got
a bunch of other really awesome stuff
the new show that we launched last
Friday the culture war with Tim pool
first episode got like 150 000 hits
which is pretty big for your average
podcast it's on YouTube though so maybe
you'd expect a little bit more we've got
a bunch of really great guests that are
coming up they're not all political
we've got a musician coming we've got uh
uh a tech guy uh the next week after
that and um I'm sorry not a tech guy we
have a very prominent cultural figure
that I I don't want to say who until we
get absolute confirmation but it's going
to be really really interesting so check
out that at youtube.com timcast where I
had a conversation for a couple hours
with Ali London who at one point he's a
British man was transgender Korean woman
and then he de-transitioned he talks
about his identity issues you can check
out the culture war with Tim Poole on
Apple Spotify and YouTube but uh smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share this show with your
friends joining us tonight to talk about
this and so much more is Justin from
Phoenix ammo
thanks for having me yeah who are you
what do you do my name is Justin I'm the
CEO of Phoenix ammunition in Novi we're
a family owned ammunition Manufacturing
Company where the self-appointed voice
of the militia industrial complex as we
like to call ourselves not the not the
military industrial complex we sell 100
of our products to
retail consumers uh no no government no
police no no contracts like that and no
Biden voters right that's right no Biden
voters but literally you banned Biden
voters yep yeah we did that we had a
disclaimer on our website for about a
year and a half that we didn't want to
sell to people who voted to uh
um ban guns you know ban guns and and
ban our way to do business so yeah from
our hands to yours we're uh the farm to
table version of the ammo industry and
uh that's who we are right on and we can
we could probably uh eventually talk
about the uh the pistol brace band
that's going in effect because it's
actually yeah a lot of people if you're
not into guns you're not concerned about
this the crazy thing about this story is
to put it simply a a federal agency has
just enacted or is is about to enact a
law without Congress where they will
jail You by decree and that's that's I
guess the scary version of the story but
we'll get in all those details so Justin
thanks for hanging out yeah we got
Hannah Claire bremelo hanging out hi I'm
Hannah clear brimlow I'm a writer for
timcastoff.com can't talk today uh Farm
to Table ammo is hilarious you should
follow at timcast news on Twitter and
Instagram thanks for having me because
grow your own black powder yeah what do
you do do you like do you scrape the bat
crap off or whatever no that's you but
that's black yeah black powder is
different
unfortunately we uh we wish we could
make our own but we're still sort of
beholden to the the suppliers it's very
different smokeless powder these days
yeah yeah black powder was that crap
planting bullets in a field and they're
like Sprout up and like bullets maybe
they can pull the carbon out of the air
that's how they would get made yes no
they used to they used to it was back
crap right yeah yeah that's crazy
nitrate if I take this back crap I can
make it I can shoot somebody that's
that's crazy Americans are so Innovative
I love it we're like Chinese but great
all kinds of people are Innovative were
they like the mines were blowing up
there why are they blowing up it's the
bat crap and then they found out that's
oh that makes sense bats are all in
caves crapping everywhere building it
could be yeah yeah watch out for that
well let's talk about that I guess we
got search pressing the buttons yo guys
I got a new mixture here so I'm gonna be
EQ and everyone as we go let's roll
here's the story from the New York Times
lab leak most likely caused pandemic
energy Department says the conclusion
which was made with low Confidence Game
as America's intelligence agencies
remain divided on the origins of the
coronavirus and I love they have this
picture of the virus Factory in Wuhan
the
tweeted remember when a virus emerged
outside of this uh in the city next to
the virus Factory and they told you you
were crazy for claiming that the virus
may have come from the city with the
virus Factory it seems crazy but anyway
so here's real quick just to show you a
couple things we get into this
conversation
I'm not saying I trust the government
okay the doe is saying this is most
likely and I'm like I agree it's just
one agency saying it's probably the case
and it probably is the case but I want
to show you these archives take you back
in time you want to read that one Ian
this is Tom Cotton keeps repeating the
coronavirus conspiracy theory that was
already debunked The Washington Post
reported this February of 2020. they
said Senator Tom Cotton repeated a
fringe Theory suggesting that the
ongoing spread of the chronovirus is
connected to research in the
disease-ravaged epicenter of Wuhan China
cotton referenced a laboratory in the
city the Wuhan National biosafety Lab
blah blah blah blah blah so uh about
that you should just then we have this
one from his like Banner on Twitter oh
he should New York Times Senator Tom
Cotton repeats Fringe theory of
coronavirus origins in an interview on
Fox News the Arkansas lawmaker raised
the unsubstantiated possibility that the
new coronavirus originated in a high
security biochemical lab in China and uh
the New York Times February 17 2020
called it a fringe Theory and today or
so there's a couple days ago it was 26
yesterday lab leak most likely caused
pandemic what's it called when you say a
bunch of stupid things and then have to
New York Times And The Washington Post
have edited those articles to remove
their stupidity from them because uh
yeah everybody's basically saying well
uh the virus probably escaped the place
that make coronaviruses I remember
seeing this on Taco Carlson right around
that time it was either the same day he
made that statement of the day after and
thinking to myself this makes the most
sense there's a lab there people don't
really understand how many leaks occur
at biosafety Labs even here in the
United States I mean that's that's how
people believe uh
what's the disease um Lyme disease yeah
a lot of people think Lyme disease was
the product of a of a BSL lab leak
that's on an island off the coast of New
York there's one in can I mean that was
a big thing for a while they were
building one in uh Fort Dietrich you
don't get to make all these movies where
the the scientist gets pricked through
their suit and they go oh God and they
run out and then have people think these
labs are completely safe yeah Lyme
disease was uh found near Lyme
Connecticut right and that's why they
call it Lyme disease they don't know
exactly where why I wouldn't be
surprised if it was I've heard the same
thing that it was done on an island like
a biomedical I just like the idea of the
federal government's like but that only
happens in movies movies are based
completely on fiction we would never do
anything like it yeah even this
announcement it still says we have
concluded meaning it is done that it
might have happened over there we don't
know it's the ultimate soft launch of a
like explanation right you know some
girls like soft launch their boyfriends
on Instagram the government is soft
launching the that they're admitting it
was from a b testing we're low
confidence we're not sure but we've done
all of our research and we're basically
but so what it what if what's the
likelihood that this is a a Cassis
Valley for war with yeah this is a
definitely an opening for a war for sure
um so if they needed one well right
think of it this way if if China invades
Taiwan how does the United States get
the American people to publicly support
a war with China blame all of covet on
them exactly remember that that you know
your parents who died it was China yeah
we just found that out and then people
are going to be screaming in the polls
and the media will come out they'll
March in lockstep but uh sure enough
you're still going to get actually this
is interesting let me walk I want to say
something different I'm going to walk it
back a little bit I'm curious would
conservatives remain anti-war if the U.S
government came out definitively across
the board and said we have direct
evidence that they were breaking
international law with with gain of
function research and they caused the
global pandemic I think so because a lot
of people know that fauci was working
with Eco Health Alliance to do the
research so it wasn't just the Chinese a
lot of people are aware that Anthony
fauci and probably the US government was
involved as well so I think that that
will be a loud noise being made and
statement that's repeated like fauci was
involved in this and so what I'm asking
is the U.S will want to go to war with
China over Taiwan
will conservatives now support
International actually I think it's the
opposite and I think that's the reason
that conservatives wouldn't support it
because like for me personally I would
say well why are we going to war with
China uh until fauci is put on trial and
until all everybody in the United States
that had any part in this is dealt with
then we can talk about China but only
until that happened that's what I mean
it would be hard to sell that going to
war would do anything do anything right
right like we're gonna send more people
to die after putting them through
everything we have the past three years
it was war and maybe this is just a very
rudimentary understanding of it you know
it's not like we'll take a chunk of land
from China and then we'll be like and
that solves everything for kovid right
like I could see issuing tons of
economic sanctions I could see breaking
trade Partnerships but actually going to
battle with them I actually feel like if
you just said it's about Taiwan there
were more Americans who'd be like okay
sounds good then if you said yeah that's
why I brought up the people knowing that
fauci was involved in in financing and
working on the stuff through Eco Health
people would not want to go to war
because they know that fauci was
involved so that would be like I'm not
gonna buy the crap you can't pin this on
China we know that there were American
scientists involved in building this
thing at least for evidence points to
that well there were fauci provided
funding and Eco Health who then provided
funding to Wuhan yeah or whatever they
pay you to pay him to pay him and do it
for me it's virus laundering or
something I think really what this is is
just a the long tail setup for their
plan for the 2024 election and I mean I
was thinking about this a year and a
half ago where
um especially if Trump runs again
they're gonna they're gonna put covid
and the vaccines and all of it on Trump
that's what I think uh I I think they're
going to say hey uh he left fauci in
office uh he pushed the vaccine through
uh too quickly because he wanted uh to
Puff his chest up and show how good he
was and look at all these people that
died as a result of Trump's ego uh so
it's all his fault it's going to be just
like you know projection is their own
what a tool so what if they come out and
they say we have now confirmed Wuhan was
doing a legal gain of function research
with the assistance of Anthony fauci
through circuitous funding and thus we
will be filing subpoenas and criminal
referrals for Anthony fauci and then
said after they arrest him we are going
to go to war with China so let's say
let's put it this way China invades
Taiwan the U.S says we're going to
defend our allies in the region but we
can't be directly involved with China oh
whoa China take the virus on purpose and
caused all this damage and hey what's
that fauci was involved fauci you're
under arrest hey guys can we go to war
now
I don't know I I gotta be honest with
you I think conservative I mean I
wouldn't really describe myself as a
conservative particularly but I think I
think the the sort of Warhawk side of
the party is uh is getting smaller and
smaller I mean you know with everything
going on in Ukraine and
I just I don't I really can't see a huge
number of people being especially China
I mean you're talking about two World
superpowers it feels like opening
another endless war right like didn't we
just get out of the Middle East in some
respects and we're already spending more
money in Ukraine than we lived in
Afghanistan I just can't you know it's
so there's so much media now that you
know these the days of like the Gulf of
Tongan and these things where they can
stage an event and they can get people
riled up and there's they've got this
like dead zone before the truth really
comes out and and then you get momentum
going and people are so uh afraid to go
back on what they said you know they're
late it's like the sunk cost fallacy I
just think that that time is coming to
an end these days I think everything's
on video I think the US I don't I don't
know maybe they're just realizing they
can't keep lying about this because any
sane Jon Stewart goes on Colbert's show
and says this makes the most sense but
I'm wondering I guess I guess I just put
it this way my prediction would be in
the event the US does want to go to war
China invades Taiwan the U.S comes out
and says oh heavens oh the lab Lake that
was China's fault the majority of the
Maga side of people
which includes some Libertarians
Independence they all say no war
and then your McCarthy's and your
McConnells your Lindsey Grahams are just
like everybody was ragging on China just
10 minutes ago and we can't allow this
you can't change your mind and now act
like they're the good guys and then the
Democrats are going to come out and be
like China's always been the bad guy
what are you guys talking about
conservatives You're such you're always
defending Xi Jinping and Hillary
Clinton's like I loved Vladimir Putin
all of these years well no they'll still
hate Russia but they're going to come
out and be like why won't you support
our Wars and then every journalist every
news Outlet's gonna come out every poll
is going to be like we surveyed 5
billion people and found that 95 want
war with China so if you don't agree
you're a weirdo and then you're gonna
get a bunch of Normie people in cities
being like Oh yeah okay I guess World
War III or whatever I bet if they that
if they were to be like and by the way
Anthony fauci is involved something
something Anthony that should be like
and by the way I have documents of
Barack Obama being involved Bill Clinton
being involved I have evidence of the
the Clinton Foundation being like if it
was all she is the Nexus of this stuff
and he knows everybody nobody that's
working on this I mean he's he's very
specifically NIH but it would be funny
if just like some guy no one ever heard
of shows up and then he just starts
putting out all this evidence on all of
these people and it's like
the government's actually run by someone
like some Shadow government no one ever
heard of like like an Epstein level guy
I mean because the the reality is that
there's probably some big corporate
lobbyists shout out to Woody Harrelson
he's talking about these cartels there's
probably some big corporate lobbyists
that you've never heard of Black Rock
State Street Vanguard whatever who come
to these people these politicians tell
them what they need in exchange for
funding and you've never heard of these
people yeah and they'll send someone to
talk to the politicians so the
politician doesn't even know who the
people are so it's not even like Shadow
government conspiracy level stuff it's
like we know these big investment firms
exist we don't know who's doing the
principal lobbying
but the politicians do yeah they know
who's coming to them and telling them
like look we need this bill passed
otherwise your Pack's not getting the
100 million dollars and they're like but
if I don't get that I don't I don't win
you're right so better get the bill
passed and they go you got a boss so
they're already uh don't those guys
already investing in Ukraine BlackRock
and oh yeah that's what I heard what an
opportunity it is and think about the
war debt Ukraine's gonna have no this
war is actually it's it's all it's more
like the US is Conquering Ukraine all
the money being given to Ukraine will
justify the US owning the whole thing or
I should say Europe and NATO owning the
whole thing because in the event that
Russia loses
Vladimir Vladimir zielinski is going to
be like yay freedom now don't forget you
owe BlackRock a hundred billion dollars
yeah and you will never pay it back well
just like China has the uh belt and Road
initiative right where they're uh
subsidizing the building of
infrastructure in third world countries
especially in Africa they're
um they're paying for the cell towers
and the freeways and that's because they
can get the data from the cell towers in
particularly but
um yeah they want them to be beholden
and I think uh that's sort of what what
we do is we go in and destroy everything
first and then we rebuild it in the way
that that we think we want to in the way
that benefits our investors and uh these
big Capital firms so you know we're fine
to watch Ukraine get shelled into
Oblivion which is what's happening right
I mean uh because not only do they have
the 100 billion in debt already but
after the war ends our firms or
shouldn't say our but International
firms come in and say okay now you're
going to rack up another 500 billion in
debt as we rebuild your country for you
yeah and we will own you forever they
don't they don't they're not going to
have the infrastructure are left at the
end so the the fact of the matter is
they can't rebuild their country without
concrete plants and you know steel uh
fiber optics all these things that
they're not going to have the capability
to make so we can go in there and do it
for them and uh that's that's really the
The Profit motivation for those
companies build a smart grid to track
and data yeah smart grid right we got to
upgrade it you know everything's going
to be Wi-Fi wireless now and uh you know
it used to be that the US would invade a
foreign piece of land and liberate it at
least in one instance the Spanish uh
when they the Spanish-American War at
the end of the 1800s they went into Cube
by the Americans and they liberated Cuba
from the Spanish Empire and Cuba became
its own thing the US didn't even want it
they weren't like pay us back as far as
I know they didn't want to extort them
or anything so Cubo is free and then
Cuba became communist and very dangerous
for the Americans so we've kind of we
should invade I'm wondering like when we
do go in to liberate is it better that
we leave Americans there to control it
or do we actually just let them be
totally free because because Freedom
isn't free we have freedom in the United
States because we have dudes with guns
pointing them at all the bad guys and
forcing this area to maintain the
semblance of what we have defined as
Freedom maybe we should like invade
these countries and then put our troops
there for 20 years and then build
military bases all around 30 years 30
years because that doesn't work either I
mean not really South Korea seems to be
working with Puerto Rico did we do that
what we should do is invade the country
and then uh hand an AR-15 to every
single Citizen and say now you guys are
on your own
I don't know you've got a fair fight
with the government now you have what we
have which is the only thing that has
kept our country from being different
from the rest of the world we're going
to liberate You by we we're going to
install the Second Amendment uh the
First Amendment and the Second Amendment
and then we're gonna I don't think it
will lead you to your devices I don't
think we don't think so nope the the the
American colonies had moral structures
and shared culture shared culture uh
moral foundations and classical liberal
principles they were they were shared
among the founding fathers so they were
kind of like leave me alone and that
worked you go to a place where it's like
authoritarian religious Fanatics and
give a bunch of guns then you're going
to get 15 different sects just shooting
each other non-stop for 50 years I'm not
saying we should go there and change
things I'm saying cultures need to
develop and get to that point there's
perhaps diplomacy that we could employ
that might help you know put them in a
direction we think would ultimately
reduce violence and increase Prosperity
but I don't think guns a First Amendment
probably
give people the right to speak freely
share ideas and you doesn't exist though
without the second yeah that's the
problem I mean I think that's right no
that's a good point yep we want them to
be able to speak freely when the
government comes to beat the crap out of
them yeah I think it's hard to accept
that if we were to go into a different
country and say you guys are free to
decide what you want that they may
install system that number one doesn't
work like do we go back then and fix it
and also they may Pick A system that we
don't like right like if communism is
what ultimately Cuba decided would work
I'm not saying it did but that was what
came out on top when they were allowed
to pick
you know
I would not if I were you know John
Kennedy or whatever I would not want to
be like ah yes Cuba you just have your
communism and hang out over here while
we have democracy but on the other hand
you just keep going in and saying like
no you have to do it our way you have to
do it all right you have to do our way
especially like we were saying before if
there are countries that are dominated
by cultural or religious pressures that
are so dissimilar to what we were
founded on like we don't have the same
kind of basic needs that other other
civilizations do I was I was talking to
Ali London on uh the culture War podcast
with Tim Poole check it out on Apple and
Spotify and youtube.com timcast one of
the interesting things he said to me uh
Shameless plug was that in Korea they
all get surgery to look like European
people like they'll get their their
chins shaved down and they'll get their
noses look at nose and plants make their
noses bigger and they'll get their eyes
made to be wider with surgery so they
can look like white people and it's a
normal thing for all of them we thought
it was like we talk about how crazy it
is that a British guy would want to get
surgery to look Korean but to him he
said he was living in Korea that was
normal
everybody was there was getting surgery
to look like the specific thing so he
was trying to look like they were
I don't think uh the U.S occupying South
Korea whatever you call whatever you
want has necessarily been good for them
but certainly it's been better than if
it was North Korea that and you know the
Communists that took over so
yeah I don't know it's like they went
the complete other other direction but
it's still better I guess it's tough to
talk with confidence about life in Korea
because I've never been but from you and
me parks first hand perspective she's a
North Korean Defector I guess because
she was able to escape the country
because you can't leave freely uh I I
believe that North Korea is absolutely
one of the biggest pieces of Hell on
Earth of Any Nation well and South South
Korea yes there are Western beauty
standards that become a part of culture
but on the other hand like America has
never generated anything like the K-pop
industry right producing K-pop stars who
then go through plastic surgeries to
look American like we we didn't we never
mastered like Korean culture is still
strong and it has some interpretations
of Western influence but I would never
say that it's lost its culture to a
western identity I went to uh
a shopping area in Seoul and they had
this advertisement for like Chicago
pizza and then one of the pizza
varieties was black squid ink and I'm
just like we don't we don't have that in
Chicago but you know it's it's tourist
stuff no way yeah it's like I went to
Thailand I went to get Pad Thai and I
was like I want squid and then my Thai
friend started laughing at me and he was
like bro it just means like shrimp
noodles like you're asking for shrimp
and noodles but like imagine ordering a
cheeseburger but with chicken just order
a chicken sandwich and I'm like in
America we have like Americanized Thai
food you know what I mean so he's like
you want to go get real Thai food and
then he brought me to an actual
restaurant and we sit down and you know
what you know what real Thai food is it
was steamed chicken and rice I was in
Brazil and I was like I want real
Brazilian food it's like all right we
got steak and rice yeah there's like
nothing complicated about it like people
around the world typically eat a lot of
this similar things different spices
depending on the area but in America we
dump sugar fat and oil on everything
spice it a certain way and we're like if
there's like brown sugar vinegar Ginger
it's Chinese if it's Curry it's Indian
but in reality it's like not really I
think a lot of the Indian food was
invented in Britain anyway there's a
really interesting documentary about uh
the spread of kung pao chicken and like
how that was developed and especially
as you came to America and you had these
Chinese restaurants there were a couple
really high-end you know culinary
experiences but a lot of them were
considered sort of cheap or convenient
meals and they spread throughout the U.S
and those they had to come up with a
dish that was like palatable to
Americans that they would eat but also
wasn't so complicated that they would
not need it it's similar to uh the man
who founded Taco Bell
he was like I'm going to uh he grew up
in California and he grew up wanting to
have a hamburger stand he was like a kid
in the depression then he went to war
and then he came back and was like their
Hamburg stands everywhere so I got to do
something else and there was a Mexican
influence in the area he grew up in and
so he was like I'll make tacos but I'll
make them with flour tortillas and with
lettuce and basically like made it the
most simple like it gets compared to a
hamburger it's not really a traditional
a Mexican taco but at the same time it's
something that people will eat and they
recognize flavor it's not too
intimidating I'm pretty sure when they
introduced Taco Bell to Mexico they
called it American food yeah I'm sure
really it didn't work nobody nobody
wanted to eat that well here's the thing
too Mexican when you go to a Mexican
restaurant you're actually going to
Tex-Mex Restaurant right like I'm sure
people have been to real Mexican
restaurants but real Mexican restaurants
like fajitas like chicken and veggies
and rice the burrito taco stuff that's
Tex-Mex like burritos too and like queso
like queso yeah
it's rough I've gone corn basically
one's better I think corn is better
let's uh stop talking about the foods of
the world and go back to the news so
we'll get back to covid we have the
story from Essence uh from from The
Washington Post I love how we were just
ragging on the Washington Post and now
we're gonna rag on them again
on Saturday Night Live Woody Harrelson
pushes popular covid-19 conspiracy
theory the actor worked in a joke during
his monologue that repeated a pandemic
plot favored by vaccination opponents
notice how she didn't say exactly in the
headline what he said
oh here it is yeah he says um do they
have the quote he says the uh in a
monologue filled with references to his
abiding use of marijuana the actor who
went that's hilarious just right there
because like the left is the has always
historically been like the pro pot and
now they're alive but now they're using
it as a cudgel to beat him with that's
right because he's not saying here's
what he said he read us he read a script
where the biggest drug cartels in the
world get together to buy up all the
media and all the politicians enforce
all the people in the world to stay
locked in their homes and people can
only come out if they take the cartels
drugs and keep taking them over and over
I threw the script away I mean who's
gonna believe that crazy idea being
forced to do drugs I'd do that
voluntarily all day long and so that was
his joke and the live audience offered
scattered laughter but viewers at home
had much more visceral reactions what I
love is it's like there's like a paradox
in this article
they're being the media is being made
fun of for calling as an anti-vaxx
conspiracy it's like well hold on there
a minute big Pharma literally lobbies
the government that's not a dispute yeah
they go to politicians more than any
other industry yeah they're massive and
they made 100 billion dollars they had
guaranteed no liability contracts and
we've all seen the video brought to you
by Pfizer brought to you by Pfizer
brought to you by Pfizer they brought us
everything cool this year they're buying
ads like crazy they buy ads like crazy
they sell products they Lobby
politicians Woody Harrelson wasn't
saying any kind of conspiracy theory he
was making a joke about every joke has
its truth big big pharmaceutical
corporations lobbied government and the
media to try and convince people to take
their drugs it's a product they got no
liability contracts made a lot of money
off it now they're calling Woody
Harrelson a conspiracy theorist but I'm
not here to talk about the negative and
I don't want to I don't want to sit here
and and and and just rag on media like
we always do I Want To Praise Woody
Harrelson and say hey look man people
are pushing back this is a mainstream
celebrity hosting SNL talking about we
should not let massive multinational
corporations dictate what we can or
can't do that seemed to be the message
right
so we're good all right
Victory yes I just think it's funny that
they're like you're a conspiracy
theorist like if you weren't if this
wasn't a direct comparison to what
you're doing you wouldn't be so
threatened by it like if you weren't
doing something Shifty don't freak out
right I I just think his monologue
first off like it wasn't the funniest
monologue in all of SNL history it's
just that he came close to a subject
that makes them uncomfortable yeah
and then everyone lined up exactly like
you thought they would like the
Washington Post everyone else is like
conspiracy theorist maybe because he was
saying people were locked in their homes
in the United States I'd have never
heard of anyone being locked in there
were in China that I heard they were
being welded into their homes so locked
in yeah China was way more secure uh
Australia were sending people to camps
where they couldn't leave their front
porch so locked in in that instance but
they're locked in Australia some
respects because you couldn't go to
school you weren't allowed to go
functionally live functionally you
couldn't alone or you weren't allowed to
go to Parks they filled in the sand pits
at the skate parks like you know what I
mean like they kept any they took away
anything that would be worth leaving
your house for I like how in Australia
they went to indigenous areas and
neighborhoods and and literally
kidnapped children and then brought them
to camps and then there was one viral
story where some teenagers jumped the
fence and escaped and ran for for it and
they got hunted down and they picked up
at a bar they were hanging out yeah and
I'm like these are concentration camps
and then people like Claire Lehman of
quelette were like no no it's not the
government taking people and
concentrating them in one area without
charge or trial is not a concentration
campus own good stop the spread and I'm
like yo the government's rounding up
indigenous Australians and putting them
in camps and they're like but because of
covet and I'm like I didn't say not
because of covet I just said they're
doing it I think that Woody making this
joke and talking about this publicly on
one of the most popular television shows
on Earth and being one of the most
popular actors on Earth alongside with
the government's acknowledgment that it
was made in the laboratory most likely
or or you know they've concluded that it
was probably done in the lab and I think
it's all happening at once and it's
great can I just uh I want to say
something because you know I have this
here uh Coca-Cola in a glass bottle that
I I just drank before the show and I
don't drink a lot of soda if if all if
you know ever but we do have guests who
do like soda and so you know I don't
want to get cans and cans are okay or
bottles plastic bottles get out of here
so we got glass bottle Coke with real
sugar real cane sugar and of course
everyone knows this is the famous
Mexican Coca-Cola and I was just
drinking this and I thought to myself
that's kind of crazy that in Mexico you
will get a glass bottle no no phthalates
no pcbs no endocrine disruptors made
with cane sugar no high fructose corn
syrup and it's probably cheaper in
Mexico in terms of buying power
so in terms of the Mexican economy how
much you have to work to get a Coke is
probably less work than in the United
States but in the U.S you're getting
plastic garbage with endocrine
disruptors and high fructose corn syrup
and that just weird like in the United
States we are poisoning and degrading
ourselves like why I don't know by
choice I mean we're I want to I think
we're the only country that mandates
fluoride in the water if I'm not
mistaken I don't know about the one it's
the only country we may be if we're not
the only it's it's very it's very few I
was going to say this earlier too just
to give people some perspective uh into
no everybody everybody does it are you
sure yeah I thought Europe oh I know you
can't in Europe most European countries
it's not mandated a bunch of the U.N
countries yeah I think the dark red ones
are mandated mandated and then the other
ones are like I don't know I don't know
we're one of the we're one of the others
what was that South American country it
doesn't explain what the different
shades mean but what is that country
which one where South America this yeah
that looks like is that Venezuela is
that Colombia and that's Columbia is it
uh Bolivian I'm so that's so sad that I
don't know that I think Colombia and
Bolivia are in the middle but let's just
check
who knows somebody knows in the chat
what were you saying I was gonna say
just for perspective so people
understand in 2022 the pharmaceutical
industry spent 284 million dollars on
lobbying right so to give some
comparison uh our my opponents Columbia
on the anti-gun side of the table always
talk about how much money that the gun
lobby spends uh it was less than 14
million
so 280 something million pharmaceutical
industry versus less than 14. maybe a
year maybe we need to get it so that you
get your the vaccines are delivered by
uh gunshot
dudes less lethal uh plastic and it'll
be like a pepper ball of some sort it
wasn't that that was X-Men right was it
oh yeah it was a cure
yeah maybe thank you maybe that's the
Roundup way you do it you have uh the
Republicans pass a law saying that
vaccines can all be delivered by by a
dart of some sort fired from a gun then
then they get the pharmaceutical Lobby
being like don't ban guns don't don't
ban them we love those they're necessary
yeah someone but then they're going to
be like you pull them to a 7-Eleven
parking lot the doctor goes don't move
hit you in the arm and you're like oh I
feel great doc you know oh what are you
saying there you go I haven't been
taking the people keep sending me these
stories about uh graphene being in the
vaccines and that people are being
trapped there's actually a patent where
they want to track People based on their
graphene and their bloodstream or
something and I just keep dismissing it
because it sounds so ridiculous but I I
just received like three messages about
it over the weekend I want to pull it up
I really do not believe there's Graphics
no there is there's graphene vaccine the
who did um died suddenly they did a
whole report on this I can send you a
link if you want but like to what extent
and what's the point of it what does it
do that is beyond my graphing knowledge
I'm going to send the report to Ian and
he'll let us all know if that's true
then I gotta I got a question in loyalty
CI who are you working for again but the
thing about materials is they'll be used
it's a plan like the nuclear bomb the
nuclear program was so amazing because
it ended up winning us the War World War
II but uh also so devastating because it
gave people access to nuclear weapons
same with graphene it's a duality to
everything yeah it'll be remaking roads
buildings rails all that but people be
making new weapons with it tracking yeah
I mean that's that's the history of the
fight I mean the reason that we have
such a robust uh defense in particular
Firearms industry here in this country
is because we won the Revolution and now
all of a sudden we're on our own uh you
know the French were our allies only
insofar as uh they want to but now they
see us as a young you know potentially
vulnerable Nation we were buying all of
our weapons from uh our allies or what
we took over with us from Britain and so
we basically had to recreate our own uh
weapons manufacturing I mean this is of
course back in the day when everything
was made by by hand right I mean Lock
Stock and Barrel that was the the old
saying so
um the corporate press that's why that's
why that's why it's such a big industry
here people don't really understand you
know they think uh how did that culture
develop here in the U.S but it was
because we had to create it literally
from scratch to be able to defend
ourselves the corporate press says no no
graphene oxide in the vaccines I wonder
if what people are confusing is that
they used graphene access oxide in the
manufacturing process that is not in the
vaccine because uh some of the things
I'm seeing are people talking about
fetal cells in the vaccine fetal cells
are used in the development of these in
like testing and and production but the
final product doesn't contain the cells
themselves I'm not like I actually
that's an argument what we saw a lot of
was people saying they didn't want to
take it because they used fetal cells to
make the vaccine and then the meat was
like no there's no fetal cells in the
vaccine well hold on that's not what
people were saying they were saying that
to make the product to invent it to test
it you used fetal cells you know so
we're not okay with that with it's like
you know it's like we in order to test
this we injected a bunch of monkeys
those monkeys died but don't worry these
vaccines contain no monkey and it's like
well that's not what I'm saying I'm
saying you killed monkeys to do it so I
don't know to what extent people are
talking about graphene oxide but I think
it was maybe in like the manufacturing
process I guess a lot of times that's a
big problem with the food industry is
they'll show you the ingredients the
food but they don't show you what
chemicals were used in the treatment of
the Machinery before the food is
processed a lot of times yeah and
sometimes you have toxic chemicals used
to clean metal or something and how do
you completely get that off especially
for like food manufacturing right you
don't I don't think you really can you
have residue you know Justin you were
talking about the weapons manufacturers
in the United States I'm wondering from
your perspective as a weapons
manufacturing company or head CEO you're
the executive like what do you what are
your thoughts on the military-industrial
complex and I'll just because lately I
used to think I didn't know anything
about them then 20 2007 I was like
they're the they're the villains now I'm
like wait we have the military
industrial complex in the United States
if it was in another country we'd be
living in the service
yeah how do you do you find them as like
an evil Unstoppable force or what do you
think about it well I mean I think
they've become that in many ways it I
mean it's it's a it's a profit
generating industry and so
um
in in today's society where it's easy
for them to say well we can just start
another war and that will be our
development ground for where we make
advancements and we test things I mean
that's that's where we are today but
that's not where it was when we began
right I mean like I said we we developed
uh this industry in the us because we
had to we had to be able to make our own
guns to defend a young uh you know up
and coming country and so
as it's developed over time and we've
like you know post World War II
obviously the rest of the world is
mostly in shambles uh we're we're
running strong
um we were really the only country left
that could produce uh much of anything
so we we basically became the supplier
to the rest of the world for uh Advanced
uh Weaponry so
as power has become concentrated in
those Industries I mean the the military
industrial complex is is a real thing
and and you know we're it's that's way
over my purview in the sense that
um you know we were very detached from
that you know they're they're they're
much larger than us
um it's it's something that I I can't
even fathom you know these are people
that are connected with politicians and
they're making back room deals and
they're writing the legislation they're
deciding where we're going to fight the
next War
um all of those things so it I think
it's an unfortunate product of
of reality you know when you have an
industry that makes money off of the
development of weapons technology
eventually somewhere along the line
um you know like the development of the
nuclear bomb so somebody looks at the
atom and says oh we could make a bomb
with this
and if that's the guy that gets all the
money and all the funding then we're
going to make a bunch of bombs and so in
the military-industrial complex uh you
have some guy in there at one point that
says hey we could actually make a lot of
money if we just started our own Wars
right instead of waiting for the next
War to happen and then figuring out how
to which side we're going to supply I
mean I think that's probably going on
forever it's like uh people have been
supplying both sides of every conflict
going back uh have you seen Sherlock
Holmes Game of Shadows the movie plot is
basically spoiler alert for this you
know 15 year old movie or whatever uh
Moriarty is he owns portions of all
these different companies and
manufacturers in different countries and
he wants a World War to start so that he
can be the financier and have debt in
all these different places and own
everything and like I guess the premise
of the film is the industrialization of
war and they like the first machine
pistol and he's like whoa It's like what
is this they're all shocked by it and
then at the and Moriarty's like War and
the world on the industrial level is
coming you can't stop it yeah well and
naturally technology typically has
something yet eclipses it and that
business dies away but with the War
Industry they just continue to up the
ante and if you give them a chance to
test it bio weapons yeah and and then we
tell other countries well you can't
develop your own like a
what whichever side you are on you know
so Iran is trying to build a nuclear
weapon and we've decided that we can't
allow that to happen and so not only do
we have these large companies here in
the U.S that are making all the weapons
but they're actively lobbying along with
politicians to not allow that kind of
weapons technology to be developed
anywhere else
yeah I mean of course it's going to be
concentrated here because we won't allow
we won't allow that industry to grow in
I mean imagine if
um
you know a pick a country pick a country
that we don't really like you know we're
going to do everything that we can
within our power I mean we really can't
tell China what to do but uh some
country that we can actually exert
influence over we're going to do
everything that we can to prevent them
from growing a weapons industry because
we don't want that to impact the
companies that we've got here yeah which
are five five of the six largest are
American the sixth is British and that's
so it's I look at it as a monopoly for
sure and you might laugh and be like duh
but like literally what they've done is
they've broken it into six companies
that are technically different companies
but they're all American British
manufacturing there's Raytheon uh
Lockheed Martin's the number one then
it's Boeing Raytheon b-a-e is the as the
British one then there's Northrop
Grumman and General Dynamics what does
BAE stand for b-a-e systems the company
I don't know what the I don't know what
somebody's initials were on the top of
my head we'll find out yeah yeah
Halliburton where you said Halliburton
halliburton's not in the top leading
weapons not really a a weapons they're
more of a of a general contractor they
they just uh yeah the nation build
exactly beyond that is Airbus which is
trans European now we're starting to
look at the non-non-british American
Alliance was there's thales in France
it's only worth nine billion the
American British ones are like 20
billion and up so they cost 240 billion
probably like 90 95 of the weapons
manufacturers on Earth something like
that are American British then you get
to Leonardo which is Italian at 8.8
billion and Alma's anti and Russian 8.5
billion that's the first Russian
manufacturing so yeah I think that there
is a monopoly on weapons manufacturing
controlled by the British Empire
American uh industry being the
weaponization arm of the British Empire
it's concerning I don't know any way
around it I don't even know if it's the
worst case scenario I mean it's better
than the Chinese I I I I'm not a war
Monger but I understand the value of War
and the necessity of it at times so yeah
and obviously those companies have
developed a lot of this technology that
have civilian uses and civilians and
some of those things started off maybe
with uh like a lot of the things that
came out of DARPA have had you know
anything having to do with lasers for
example lasers have a lot of scientific
uh research uses they also have uh use
for offensive Weaponry there's just no
way around that you know the internet
um all of these things are a lot of them
are products of of weapons development
and and DARPA and the government
investing in things and you have some
aspect that's going to be useful for
civilian purposes and then you're going
to have some aspect that's going to be
useful for military purposes roads
that's another example the Roman
roadways was like the greatest military
breakthrough way to move troops exactly
yeah how did you start your business I'm
just curious you guys might know the
origin story already
um kind of happenstance to be honest
with you so uh this was in 2015 I was
working for an insurance company and it
was an insurance company that
specialized in dealing with
manufacturers so um everybody I dealt
with around the Detroit area was in the
manufacturing business of some kind a
small tool and die shops all the way up
to Big Plastics manufacturing companies
uh with you know 200 employees that was
kind of our niche market and so I I was
looking to get out of that industry and
I I had developed an affinity for what
they did I saw these guys that you know
they were building whatever widgets
parts and on the worst day of their
lives you know they their wife could be
divorcing them they they could be having
the the crappiest day possible but they
could look at the product that they made
and be satisfied that they put their
craftsmanship into it yeah and so I I
was jealous of them in that way because
you know it's a book full of paper that
you hope you never have to open because
that's the worst day of your life
probably you know so um my younger
brother was working for a small
ammunition reloading company at the time
and you know this was like the tail end
of the Obama presidency so this was post
Sandy Hook uh there was a big boom in in
the Firearms industry as a result you
know there was a lot of Regulation that
people were afraid of the cost of
ammunition was really high because the
demand was very high and again at the
same at that time the whole ammo
industry was controlled by a small group
of companies you know Winchester
Remington Federal these these big
players so you had a lot of small
companies starting to get into the
business of making ammo because they saw
a market for it and so uh the guy who
owned the company that he worked for
passed away and it was like a side
business he was like a rich guy had a
couple of other businesses so uh my
brother called me and said hey I think
we can buy this equipment for not that
much money I know you're thinking about
wanting to do something else what do you
think about this and so
I thought about it for a while we bought
the equipment and I I wrote a you know
it was in April of 2015 so my background
is finance and and that type of thing so
I wrote a business plan and we put the
pieces together I tried to find some
Venture Capital some money to fund it
you know struck out on that and
basically decided I was gonna cash in my
retirement plan and kind of go all in so
we got up and running right before the
2016 election or you know 2015 2016
election did you do that like did you
want to be ahead of an election year
does that influence gun sales or Amazon
well it was sort of happenstance
that we got everything lined up before
the election so we had a couple of
months where it was a good run-up
because you know everybody knew Hillary
Hillary was going to win yeah and so
the whole gun industry was kind of
freaking out she's going to ban
everything
um I knew a lot of people who bought
their first gun because they were afraid
Hillary Clinton yeah I mean and I I was
a consumer in the gun industry post
Sandy Hook so I was doing that I I you
know I bought a 200 uh AR-15 lower
receiver like a bunch of other people
you know does that is that what
determines commercial gun sales in
America like put pending regulations or
pending political turmoil I say that one
more time is that what sort of dictates
like if people are going to suddenly buy
a lot of guns it's not like they're like
oh it's Christmas time we're gonna uh
buy everyone again I mean it is seasonal
as well people buy stuff around the
holidays uh for sure it's kind of a
winter sport here in the Midwest as well
people shoot mostly at indoor shooting
ranges and so it tends to be a bit
seasonal but yeah I mean it it
definitely tracks with the political
cycle it it does for sure so we uh we
got up and running and then obviously
the election didn't go the way that
people thought and so there was a bit of
a struggle for the first couple years
while we tried to figure out
um you know the demand and is is
dropping so you can't just be the guy
with the ammo that people are going to
buy at any price you have to find a
niche and so that got us into
competitive shooting in particular
people that uh do training classes that
are big consumers high volume consumers
are willing to pay a little bit more for
a premium product so it was actually
great for us in that sense I mean if if
Hillary would have won and
um we would have been able to just sell
whatever because people would buy
whatever it'd be a difference we
wouldn't have been able to develop the
brand the way that we have and and uh so
I'm kind of thankful for that I would
say in retrospect let's jump into this
next story we have from NBC people I see
people are super Chan about this U.S
Marshals service suffers major security
breach that compromises sensitive
information senior law enforcement
officials said the incident did not
involve the database involving witness
security program blah blah blah but
they're going to say sensitive
information the affected system contains
law enforcement sensitive info including
returns from legal process
administrative information personally
identifiable information pertaining to
sub subjects of usms Investigations
third parties and certain U.S Ms
employees Wades at the incident occurred
February 17th when the Marshall service
discovered a ransomware and data
exfiltration event affecting a
standalone usms system it's got me
thinking
in the event of war with China you know
what I think they're going to do
I think they're going to release
everybody's private info you think China
will you say I mean maybe China's
somebody one of the most powerful cyber
attacks you can do is not a nuclear one
of the most powerful uh acts of War
would not be a surveillance balloon or
even a bomb it would be taking
everybody's data and Publishing it yeah
yeah people would you know we've talked
about this before
a lot of people said that when the
Soviet Union fell in like everyone's
secret files got released everyone just
agreed to shut up and not bring it up
because everybody had bad stuff in there
yeah but yo it's gonna get crazy when
like you know some leftist teachers DMS
get released and they're saying a whole
bunch of racial slurs it's gonna dish
like it's gonna be nuts so I I was I was
seeing the story and I'm just thinking
about to what extent are some of these
cyber attacks acts of War think about it
for inter okay so maybe it's
embarrassing if someone publishes your
web browser history or something right
but what if a foreign Nation publishes a
a all the criminal court proceedings and
all the communications from
investigators just completely disrupting
our legal system especially if they
weave in uh falsehoods Within These huge
dumps of of truths and then they could
pick like specific little things where
like a piece of data is is slightly
skewed to make something look make
someone look guilty or someone not look
guilty I find myself imagining when you
get those calls it's like we want to
call you by your extended warranty like
what if they stole everyone's data they
leak it and then you just bombard every
communication system so there's no way
to get actual information class and that
sounds a little bit ridiculous but if
you made it so that no one wanted to
pick up their phone no one wanted to you
know check their email no one wanted to
communicate with you at all they
couldn't trust that their identity
hadn't been stolen I mean it would be
chaos but it's not about your identity
being stolen those phone calls can serve
two purposes the first is my phone rings
I think I got like seven scam calls
today it's like scam likely just endless
and then I get voicemails that are just
in Mandarin I can't do anything with
that all it does is waste my time but
you have to think about it this way you
ever see a movie Office Space yeah and
they're like we were a program that
takes fractions of a fraction of a penny
from these transactions over a long
period of time we'll make a bunch of
money
China's probably looking at it in a
similar way in terms of War I'm not
saying these phone calls are coming from
the Chinese government maybe but think
about it this way if a phone call
disrupts an individual worker in the
United States by .0001 of their daily
productivity that's me it means nothing
to the individual but as a collective
the entirety of the United States that
could be seriously damaging it could it
could you know stack up to the point
where all of that it's like strapping a
weight to the ankle of the American
economy they are slowing us down the
other thing is if people actually answer
the phone and it's calling about your
extended warranty and they give in to
these scams and give money away now
they're actually stealing resources they
can then use in their war effort
yeah yeah you shoot a 400 000 missile at
a balloon and you wasted four hundred
thousand dollars but if you spend
because it wasn't way more than that it
was well it was per missile I think they
shot two so it was total but uh well all
right but yeah you spend 100 Grand on
missiles or you spend 800 grand
um putting together some you know
algorithm and and you what's your costs
the data basically that's your only cost
and it can just run in the background
when the US says whatever you want when
the US has the internet knocked out we
all go oh geez the internet's out but
how much economic activity is disrupted
by that yeah slowing U.S growth and
allowing and then China carries on as
you know nothing happens in Canada last
year there was a big internet outage one
of the telecommunications companies went
down and I mean it was it was not just
workers but also bus systems because all
of the bus passes are hooked up to the
Internet so you can't get anywhere I
mean it went on for like two the outage
was I think 24 maybe over that and uh
the the chaos that ensued it took a long
time it took several weeks to recover
from because the city was just not
prepared to lose the internet and with
China stealing and releasing data it in
particular it's challenging to think
about because you just don't know how
much data has been released and
collected by China I mean I know we saw
all it was like 26 States now have
specifically banned tick tock on
government-issue devices and government
networks because part of tick tock's
policies is that it collects not just
information on your phone but also your
browsing history and on your keystrokes
and all of these things like if you had
that but you were a government worker
and so you were on the DMV Wi-Fi and so
you have all of this information and
you've been looking up different things
for people like that's a lot of very
sensitive data that's just sitting in
this app's purview China if you're
listening name your price for Eric
swalwell's browser history
I think Fong Fong was watching you know
like they probably got it they were
probably working on that together plus
like if someone's got I think kind of
along the lines of what you're saying if
someone's got tick tock on their phone
and then they got my name and number and
email address and their phone as a
contact now the CCP has my my email
address well I think something
Facebook's already been doing I mean
Facebook collects your brows you're like
if you have a Facebook Messenger open it
can read all your other tabs on your
computer so there's no way to put it
back in the Box wait Facebook Messenger
can read all the tabs on your browser
it's either Facebook or Facebook
Messenger in their terms of service they
can like if you have it open they can
read the other stuff that's going on
they can like collect the data I don't
know about on a computer how that would
work on a on a phone I would understand
it's on any internet browser I mean I'm
not an expert but this is something that
I had been told I know that websites all
have the Facebook tracker so Facebook
knows where you are all the time the
scariest thing about Facebook is the
shadow profiles you guys know about that
yeah yeah they build that based on the
contacts in your phone exactly all that
other data all the data they collect
from everywhere builds up profile on you
whether you want it or not yeah isn't it
really funny wasn't the CIA working on
some program
you know about tracking the life of
every single person and then they cancel
the program and then Facebook launched
they're on the same time really like the
same time
yeah what was that called I think the
people in the chat will know that the
CIA or something was working on some
some program called like life track or
something like that and they wanted to
create profiles on everybody and then
all of a sudden they just canceled the
program
then Facebook starts it's like somebody
probably went to the boss and said why
are we going to do all this work
tracking people and we can just convince
them and do it for us yeah they'll beg
us to post their photos and share do you
feel like we're on the defensive you
know they're saying lifelong and I say
life Vlog is that what it was called
that's kind of crazy
your security guy do you feel like we're
on the defensive with this like DARPA
lifelong reacting to someone collecting
our data as opposed to actively securing
it yeah I I think
you know part of that's a product of
when you got into the into the tech age
I mean I'm 37 so I had a phone when I
was 12 but I like wasn't allowed to use
it unless it was an emergency and you
know phone plans at that time had 500
texts a month and so it was just a
different age
um but like this is I'm I'm kind of like
a Bitcoin guy and so there's a lot
there's a whole segment of uh the the
Bitcoin industry that's uh really into
the security side of it and
so
it just depends on how you started right
like people once you once you start
going down a path you're unlikely to
shift so people who have started using
technology uh before thinking about
security as being something that they
should think about are probably unlikely
or in some cases not even it's not even
really possible for them to go all the
way back to square one and build
security from the ground up like if if
you're if you're doing 10 things that
are unsecure and then you decide well
I'm going to start taking security
seriously well it's probably already too
late unless you're going to get a new
phone number you're going to completely
get rid of anything that you used prior
and you're and you're going to start
from scratch
um so I think your average person is
just very unlikely to do that so you
have to think about where does it make
the most sense like so for me when I got
into Bitcoin
um you know I was kind of uh of a Neil
fight in it at the very beginning I was
just paying attention to what was
popular in the media uh and then I
actually went to a Bitcoin a conference
called guns in Bitcoin last year and
started talking I mean like I was the
dumbest guy in the room honestly these
guys were some of the smartest people
I've I've ever been around but it was
funny how much we had in common with
them uh which was kind of the point of
the conference it was a lot about 3D
printing guns and Bitcoin and you know
self-sovereignty and um two different
groups looking at the same problem from
a different perspective and so
um thinking about okay well if you're
gonna have your own Bitcoin like well
are you really in control of it you know
do you know your keys are you connected
to your own node do you have a secure
wallet like you know you so in that case
yeah like I'm pretty confident that I've
done the right things in that one area
of my life but are there a bunch of
other ways that I'm I'm probably
deficient from a security perspective
yeah well the majority of people like
you're saying just never think about I
mean like in the gun Community a big
thing has been like we know that uh the
we know that Facebook and
um Instagram and the tech companies are
developing ways to pull the serial
number off of photos of guns so if you
take a photo of a gun and they can see
the serial number they are digitizing
that just like you do you you know
character recognition uh OCR and so
that's a big thing that was a big thing
for a while you got you can't show your
serial number on the internet because
then they'll know that it's yours and
then they're are going to build this
Shadow registry that supposedly they're
not allowed to do but we all know that
they are so like in my case I mean
there's so many pictures of my guns out
on the internet like what can I do at
that point um now going forward I could
make sure that I don't do that with
anything that I don't want them to know
that I have yeah but once you've once
you've let that cat out of the bag it's
pretty hard to put it back in let's talk
about Scott Adams ladies and gentlemen
we have this tweet from Scott Adams he
says my publisher for non-dilbert books
has canceled my upcoming book and the
entire backlist still no disagreement
about my point of view my book agent
canceled me too I'm not sure what he
means by still no disagreement about his
point of view but uh here's the story
because there's a lot of people
disagreeing with this point of view
of newspapers canceled Dilbert comic
strip accuse Scott Adams of racism there
is some Nuance to the conversation being
had here that the media is overlooking
in what Scott Adams said albeit I
disagree with what Scott Adams
prescription for the prop for the for
the issue is
Rasmussen published this
black Americans only quote it's okay to
be white 53 agree 26 percent disagree 21
not sure that's kind of a crazy scary
number that 26 percent of black
Americans think it's are they disagree
with the idea that it's okay to be white
and 21 aren't sure that's kind of scary
quote black people can be racist too 76
percent agree 27 disagree eight percent
not sure so let me play for you what
Scott Adams said which resulted in his
absolute cancellation Dilbert's being
canceled his book is being canceled he
says his career is over here's what he
said so if if you know nearly half of
All Blacks are not okay with
no bring to this poll not according to
me
according to this poll
that's a hate group
and I don't want to have anything to do
with them
and I would say you know based on the
current way things are going the best
advice I would give to white people is
to get the hell away from black people
just get the away
wherever you have to go just get away
because there's no fixing this
can't be fixed
right this can't be fixed you just have
to escape
so that's what I did I went to a
neighborhood where you know I have a
very low black population
because unfortunately there you know
there's High correlation between the
density and this is going to Don Lemon
by the way
um so here I'm just quoting Don Lemon
when when he notes that the when he
lived in a mostly black neighborhood
there were a bunch of problems that he
didn't see in white neighborhoods
so even Don Lemon sees a big difference
in your own quality of living
based on where you live and who's there
so I think it makes no sense whatsoever
as a white citizen of America to try to
help black citizens anymore
it doesn't make sense it is no longer a
rational
impulse
and so I'm I'm gonna
I'm gonna back off from being helpful to
Black America because it doesn't seem
like it pays off
like I've been doing it all my life and
have been the only outcome is I get
called a racist that's the only outcome
it makes no sense to help black
Americans if you're white the the it's
over
don't don't even think it's worth trying
totally not trying
and
there we go
you didn't expect that today did you so
I I don't get what his point is I mean
first of all he's he's very very wrong
uh he makes the point about Don Lemon
saying even in these neighborhoods I'm
like yeah Don Lemon did say that Don
Lemon did this thing in 2013 where he
was like if you live in the black
community stop littering start doing
these things and then I just brought up
like I don't know about these other
cities I know that in Chicago and Hyde
Park which has double the black
population on average than the than the
country's average it's actually very
wealthy and very nice and has some as
University of Chicago and uh you walk
around and everything is beautiful down
there for the most part and you go to
other neighborhoods like where I grew up
and there's a bunch of scummy white
trash white people with you know cars no
tires in the front of their house and
and trash like that so I I I don't know
maybe it's just me because I'm in the in
the mix of it I don't see that I don't
know what he's talking about but uh now
his book is canceled
his non-dilbert books are canceled his
entire backlist here's here's what I
think when the left has psychotic racist
opinions nobody bats an eye nobody gets
canceled the left can literally advocate
for racial segregation and they do and
they implement it all the time and
there's no repercussions and then Scott
Adams comes out and says he doesn't like
this so he's going to move and he thinks
other people should as well and I'm like
I disagree with you Scott Adams I don't
I don't like stereotyping based on a
race that doesn't solve the problem and
it doesn't actually get to the root of
what is actually going on just because
they pulled this group of people doesn't
actually answer any of the questions
that we're trying to have answered but
uh but that's fine he's allowed to have
his opinion I'm just saying there's
clearly leftist crt-based racism which
is very very similar in many ways well I
mean it's literally just like old school
white supremacy with a with a mask put
on it is totally acceptable and fun I'm
not Derek Bell the critical race
theorist who's pro-segregation that's
acceptable in these schools Scott Adams
who says basically the same thing but in
a different way that's really really bad
I think it's all bad but it's clearly a
double standard
I think he's been sort of on a slow
cancellation anyways like this is maybe
the nail in his public coffin but he got
dropped by a big public or public
publisher who has like 70 newspapers
earlier last year because he had this
character who's black but identifies as
white and he was making some joke about
like ESG scores and got contacted by
publisher for like I think it was 73
newspapers and they're like we're not
going to run your comic anymore I
understand why this is like
uncomfortable and shocking and I don't
think that he's right about the way he's
interpreting all of this data but I
think that he has been sort of uh
and a a growing Target for cancel
culture anyways you're right that about
the way he's interpreting this data is
wrong he took a poll of a thousand
people and then he said something about
all of Americans and that people should
run away from black people because of
this thousand person poll that isn't
even confirmed I don't know if it's
actually 72 Rasmussen said that they
pull online so people elect to take it
and then it's Nationwide so
theoretically people come from a
cross-section of society theoretically
people could lie the people who answer a
poll like that are the people who are
going to answer yeah I mean that's
that's the problem that the gun industry
has the same thing that's one of the
problems with polling right like you if
you just put out one poll and you're
like and we've now decided it's
indicative of something but you would
need to do more research to really get
to the bottom of it and he he says in
the beginning just so you know this is
all based on this one poll I'm basing my
entire belief structure on this poll now
and he starts claiming things as if the
poll is right dude Scott you brought it
on yourself man it is crazy that 26 of
people would be like no it's not okay to
be it's not 26 percent of people 26 of a
thousand people yeah of black
respondents yeah which are worthy even
black I mean can you prove it I can't I
don't know any this poll your question
of trust is not a question of the
argument well he makes a definitive
claim based on this unverifiable poll
and if it is verified it's a thousand
people if this is true that's what the
poll says then therefore then he
extrapolates then therefore the entire
world is that way so he must make
decisions based on well big mistakes
Scott and you're you're not you're not
actually answering what Hannah Claire
was talking about
uh in what way your Hannah clay was
talking about how it's crazy that you
know 26 of the the respondents
identifying this way said this thing now
you can extrapolate whatever 26 of
people that was why 26 of black
respondents said that they think it's
not okay to be white is it 1 000 did you
actually it's 1 000 for the whole poll
yeah I thought it was like 130 I think
that the 26
is a smaller population 30 total
respondents right if I remember so Scott
made a broad sweeping Claim about
Society based on 100 he actually said he
moved away because of things like this
and I'm kind of like yeah that's that's
because he already did it he didn't he's
not saying I'm moving he already he
already left right I've been of the
belief that maybe Scott would come on
the show one day like he's been very
vocal about critical race Theory and
like he seems like he's got an awareness
about things in society but at the same
time I gotta say Dilbert I think is one
of the most boring cartoons ever made I
used to watch it in the 80s and 90s or
read it in the 90s in the paper and be
like oh sure it's hot out there today
huh Dilbert yeah he's drinking coffee
he's like got donuts there yeah and then
that's the end of the comic and you're
like what in the hell kind of dreary
because this comic's boring I I liked
Dilbert because my my dad is a software
engineer and he he is like it is I mean
it was just it was very similar I just
hope that Calvin and Hobbs guy stays out
of this whole District
I don't know how you guys feel about it
if Scott wants to come on I don't know
if you guys are even interested in
talking to the guy but I think you know
I just like I don't like seeing people
get canceled in general I I just like
more information right like I I think
the poll is sort of doing a disservice
because there's no follow-up as far as
we know I mean it's really easy to put
some shocking stats on Twitter and to
not dive into your point right it's only
a thousand people we need more research
to see intensely it is strange that of a
thousand people of the portion that are
African-American they would respond that
like a quarter of them would say it's
not okay to be white that that is
unusual it's not what I would it's it's
unusual but I I think It suffers from
the same problem that you have uh in
like I said with with gun topics you'll
get these polls uh that the anti-gun
Lobby puts out that says ninety percent
of gun owners
um support Universal background checks
and the question is always okay well how
did you phrase the question and and who
did you pull I'm 100 confident that if I
walked into my Jiu Jitsu gym and I
talked to every single black person who
trains there they would look at me like
I was growing a second head yeah I asked
on this question and here and I just
it's so it's like
if you if you go like go outside and
touch grass you know get out into the
real world get away from these poles
like stop stop letting these polls run
your life you know I I can empathize
with the fact that you know like if that
was really true would your advice be
valuable I mean maybe but we'll see I
would want to know well so we have a way
to resolve that yeah you're going to
make it worse we have the polling data
right here from Rasmussen one thousand
Americans the question they asked was do
you agree or disagree with this
statement quote it's okay to be white
now I think one of the things that
people need to understand here
especially Scott Adams is the people who
responded may have already seen the
media campaign that claimed the phrase
it's okay to be white was a racist dog
whistle right in which case that 26
percent may be like I saw that in the
news that the white supremacists were
putting that stuff out there so no I
don't agree with it right that's not
like if I saw a poll that said is it
okay to be black like I would I would
like I'm not gonna answer these
questions right stupid do you agree with
black lives matter could be a similar
question you're like I don't like the
corporation so I say no but if you do
believe that black lives matter in
general exactly if someone the question
would be Do You Believe In Black lives
or do you believe black lives matter and
that means two things
in the general sense the the the uh
proper we could say the proper noun is
do you believe organization quote
bracket black lives matter and then the
the the generic is do you believe that
black lives in fact matter to other
people like
because black lives matter is an
organization that question means two
different things to different people you
know do you believe in do you believe
you know do you support do you support
black lives matter are you talking about
the nonprofit or the general concept
whatever we're not going to tell you
because then what we're going to do is
once we get the answer we want and most
people say yes we then put out our
answers saying when surveyed most
respondents said they did support the
organization black lives matter and I
would get when I was doing um a lot of
administrative Minds I'd have to look at
like is this too hot for TV kind of
stuff and stuff would come in and say
it's okay to be white and then it would
show like this white woman with like
long blonde hair in a field with like an
Aryan race symbol on the on the picture
and it's like everything about that's
legal but I know what they're trying to
say is it okay to be a white supremacist
it's okay to be white and it's okay to
just tell everyone I'm white and it's
great like it's okay and like at some
point you got to stop being racist it's
not okay to be racist like it doesn't
matter what your skin color is at some
point
um what does that mean it's not okay to
be racist I clarify that just being
racist I mean I I like talking about the
difference in genetics of races and
historological you know things like that
if that's considered racism then that's
I think that's an okay conversation but
if you're going to make your life future
choices based on what happened in the
past that's a mistake or based on what
skin color people have that I think I
think the issue is what kinds of people
do that I think the problem is that
we're we don't want to implement
government based on race we don't want
to implement policy based on race we
don't want to give out loans or anything
based on race we want to judge people
based on account of their characters if
an individual holds a belief I don't
know if that's not okay or okay morality
and ideas change so if some guys got
really bad views and keeps them to
itself like that's fine you can believe
whatever you want to believe just don't
go around hurting people that's true
it's okay to hate it's just not okay to
act in violence People based upon it but
Scott Adams is getting his like he's not
getting published anymore because he
expressed his personal opinion on his
own podcast like is that's just cancel
culture at that point right he's allowed
to have an opinion we don't agree with
does that mean that his work where that
work is not going to be canceled he
didn't have something to do with this
right he didn't publish a poll where
like or like a cartoon that has this
poll quoted in it right he did tell
people to can you imagine Dilbert coming
out and being like hey dogbert I
recommend you yeah he told actually it
would be healed I believe he's like his
black white identifying character Adam
is like I've got to move because it's
crazy out here he told people to
segregate I think that's the big problem
of this video it wasn't just him saying
this is how I feel he was saying if
you're white you should get away from
black like that's to me is insanity but
it's his opinion though like should we
cancel him over his opinion well his
stuff was only on people's newspapers
because they their opinion was that it
was good right but that didn't change
the content of his work right like if
you had someone who mows your lawn and
he said to you like I love communism
it's awesome like maybe you'd let him go
but also maybe you'd be like but you do
a good job and you show up on time for
work so you can don't you cannot
don't don't give them your money to
people that hate you exactly agreed
don't don't don't don't fund bad things
so at this point I'm kind of like I
don't know if a guy came out and was
like I'm here to mow your lawn but I'm
also a hardcore communist and the money
you give me yeah I mean have a nice day
bye it's hard for me to criticize
because for a year and a half we told
people who voted for Biden that we
literally didn't want their money so it
you know with cancel culture is tough I
mean you you have to uh I think a better
way for him to phrase it would have been
look if this poll is right and if 26 of
people have uh an opinion of you that's
obviously not going to change and and is
an untenable opinion then maybe you
should think about how you organize your
life to avoid those kinds of people
people who think uh poorly of you now
you you know that's you can take that
for for what what you will I mean it
doesn't mean that you have to move away
from black people it means that you
don't want to be around people who think
that you're a bad person I mean I don't
want to be around people who think I'm a
bad person either I'm not going to hang
out with people who
um you know are critical of me being in
the gun industry right and you know tell
me that uh you know your business is
built on the backs of dead kids or
whatever I mean I you know I'm not gonna
have a beer with that guy yeah but you
know there are plenty of people in my
gym I train with who
um are uh Democrats and are on the
liberal end of the spectrum and and you
know but but we get along like we can we
can tease with each other and you know
we're we're friendly enough that we
don't have to separate ourselves but I
think if you're going to do something
like what uh Scott Adams did like you
better have all your ducks in a row
because you are going to get canceled
well he he knew this you better have the
internet it already said in advance and
I think the issue is that he's almost
right in that if you're talking about a
group of people that outright say they
don't think it's okay to be a certain
race like you don't want to live near
those people if you're of that race so
if you take the racial context out that
Scott Adams had black people are white
people or anything like that and say
if 26 of a racial group said it is not
okay for you to be that racial group
would you want to live by them imagine
if it was the other way around imagine
if the poll was white people ask is it
okay to be black and a black guy said
you got to get away from these people
well the reality is they say it all the
time these activists not all black
people leftists activists say all the
time get away from white people
whiteness is bad there was a one of the
a guy who was editor-in-chief had his
Twitter band said down with whiteness
with a bunch of black fists and I'm like
all of that stuff is widely acceptable
in the corporate press it's widely
acceptable to these newspapers ABC News
funded and a Disney Corporation
Univision Corporation was absolutely 100
okay with their editor-in-chief putting
up a Twitter Banner saying down with
whiteness okay so when Scott Adams comes
out forgive me if I roll my eyes a
little bit and don't care that much that
a guy has an opinion I don't agree with
because I am swimming in a psychotic
racism of the left for a decade or
longer yeah I think you're right it just
reminds me of the conversation that
we've had about a national divorce right
whether or not we actually formally
enter a war culturally people are
pulling away from each other because
they feel as though they're being pitted
against one another which is ultimately
extremely destructive but you can't
blame someone of any race if you're told
this race hates you or this race is
constantly oppressing you why would you
want to live next to them right if
you're fed that constantly it's meant to
keep you apart I'm not surprised that
Scott Adam who seems extremely depressed
in this video is like yeah I don't want
I don't want to be around someone of
this race who apparently doesn't like me
but what kind of short-sighted mind
would look at a poll of a thousand
people I don't even know if he knows
that how many people are in the poll
would look at a poll and then make a
life decision about all people based off
that that it's just a low hanging like
mentality that that kind of mind it
doesn't sound like it's based off this
one pole because he already has moved
away he said you know what I mean like
he is showing signs that this is
confirmation of something he has already
felt and now we're just seeing it in
hard numbers like if you have a feeling
about something and then it gets
confirmed in the data even if the data
is not the best source it's hard not to
then be like okay I made the right
decision moving away because he's
talking about it in the past tense I
don't know that's just my perspective on
it I think that he seems like this is
confirming something that he is already
upset about it but it's like what kind
of data is he using to confirm his his
suspicions like it's it's a thousand
it's not good data but like I said he's
been slowly canceled for years and years
and years I mean they've been yeah the
right calls him clot Adams
was he all for the vaccine or something
so he gets canceled on both sides but I
mean I can respect him for at least
speaking up as he you know as he
believes because he's clearly I wouldn't
call the guy a grifter no he's just
going at anybody he disagrees with him
saying exactly what he thinks even when
everyone's yelling at him he's like
that's what I think when he in the very
beginning of that video he was like the
thing is All Blacks the thing about
blacks he's not even like black people
blacks it's like a 1950s too yeah I
think he calls them white he might he
might say whites later in the video says
it once blacks it's like a 1950s George
McGovern racism oh come on I don't call
people I feel like you you call him
upset about him so you're you're reading
more into it like if I told you oh yeah
this guy said this crazy thing like you
may not feel the same sort of vitriol
like it seems like you have a specific
antipathy and like I don't it's very
rare that well-known people come out and
tell me to segregate away from black
people it was freakish to hear this come
out of a guy's name really but if a
black person said to you like I don't
like being around white people and I'm
Gonna Leave would you be angry at them
yeah I'd be also freaked out that's
crazy really yeah I don't yeah that'd be
nice they do it all all people of
actually
except for white liberals who hate being
around white white people every racial
demographic self-segregates I understand
like you want to be around what you're
familiar to an extent
there's literally
Nate so there are historical
neighborhoods that were by policy
created to be racially segregated but
for the most part these days it is all
self-segregation I understand wanting to
be around what you're familiar with but
to run away from someone is to is to me
is absolutely just the it's the
antithesis of of humanity so to be like
I it's not that I want to go where the
people look like me it's if someone's
mentality is I want to get away from the
people that don't look like me then
they're crazy you can make your Society
the way you want it it doesn't matter
why is that like crazy I mean it's just
like they're afraid for no justifiable
reason but what he's saying is they're
saying they don't think it's okay to be
the race that I have no choice but that
yeah the problem is running into is that
what he's really getting at is he
doesn't want to be around people who
don't think uh he should exist
rationally or don't think that he should
exist yeah they're questioning whether
he should exist but you can't tell that
from somebody based on their outward
appearance you have to have a
conversation with them and understand
where they're coming from hey do you
think I should exist I mean like that's
not just something that you're going to
ask to remember when you move in so you
know he's taking it to the extreme and
saying well because of because they're
black and that's something that I can
visually see that I'm going to decide to
self-segregate from those people when in
reality you know if you had a
conversation with everybody on the
street who was black you know probably
almost nobody would actually have that
opinion but he's unfortunately taking it
to the extreme remember that uh not
having the conversation that guy was
being interviewed and uh it was like it
was a guy and a woman and the woman says
well you don't understand because you're
white and he goes what he's like I'm
black and she's like you are and he's
like yes and then she was like I didn't
know and she genuinely thought his
opinion that was because David Webb yeah
he's a conservative uh talk show host
yeah and she didn't know who he was so
she accused him of being a white guy and
he was like what it's like what are you
talking about these people on the left
they live in a world where race is a is
political Viewpoint right so if you have
a conservative political Viewpoint that
means you're white but but I mean it
literally that's what they call
whiteness they've they've now started
saying like uh Polish people aren't
white and I'm like Lou gradkowski is
blonde hair and blue eyes well it
doesn't matter he is not white and I'm
like okay you're basically just saying
people I disagree with are white you
know in Scott's defense he's uh his
behavior right now is a result of five
years of racialization of people saying
whiteness is evil Blackness is evil
whiteness is great it's okay to be black
like all this crap this identity crap
you get people like Scott things like
that coming out of people like Scott's
mouth that corporate company's profit
off of if you went to Target during
February they had all kinds of like
black is beautiful like merch and stuff
which like is great if you're trying to
make sure that like young black kids in
America feel empowered right but also it
does set a weird tone where you're
saying like let's talk about race
constantly and constantly say you know
don't forget that white people did this
bad thing it's feeding critical race
Theory even when you want to avoid it
when you want to treat people to look
Beyond skin color you got what Morgan
Freeman I think it could be um someone
else just came out and said stop calling
me a black man call me a man like sure
once you get become successful you
realize I don't want the handouts I
don't want the easy money not Don Lemon
Don Lemon went on TV like what was like
a year or two ago and he said he wants
everyone to see him as a black man such
a problem he wants it to be his race
um the other who else someone really
really do from Training Day what's his
name uh Denzel Denzel just came out and
said something similar like I just just
call me a dude like don't call me a
black dude just call me a dude a man I'm
a guy and when you attain success you
realize you don't you kind of start to
see past that the skin color and all
that crap and you realize like the
content of your character is really what
makes you great and so that's it's
wonderful that people at that tier are
able to speak out and claim that
that's the way when you start looking at
people as people start calling Morgan
Freeman a man and not even registering
his color when you're talking to him
then you're not a racist that's when you
were actually out of it I think I think
people spent too much time worrying
about if they're racist or not I feel
like you don't spend enough time getting
to know the people around you you're so
obsessed with how your actions are
perceived right like you should be more
comfortable with your neighbors than how
the internet's going to label you right
the crazy thing is how Republicans have
historically been the not caring as much
about race like the first members of the
first black member of Congress I think
was Republican obviously Abraham Lincoln
was a republican the Democratic party
has consistently done things that just
cause massive damage to the black
community and the black family even to
this day and so look forgive me if I
just think like the Democrats are the
are substantially more well I don't I
don't think Republicans are racist at
all I think everyone's got racism to a
certain degree you see in those charts I
was talking about where white liberals
don't like white people white
conservatives have a slight in group
preference Latinos have a slight
in-group preference that means like for
the most part a white person a black
person Latino person is they're not
going to care about any of this stuff
they'll live next to you they'll go to
your barbecue but there's a small
percentage that prefer to be around
their own race and then white liberals
small percentage too prefer not being
around their own race or whatever
but yeah I don't know whatever that's
what I've actually enjoyed
one of one of the things I've enjoyed
the most about gun culture is how it's
becoming much more of a Melting Pot you
know I've been working with majesture
and black guns matter basically from the
beginning for like five years
um he was the first person that I
actually sponsored and
um a ton of other things have have come
from there and you know that's something
that I recognized right away was
there's just a certain amount
there's parts of
culture that I'm never going to
understand and so I can't speak to the
things that he can speak to and so the
more that you get to understand it like
Hey we're all coalescing around the same
thing which is we believe that everybody
has the right to self-defense and you
have some people that are going to focus
like yeah you know a lot of these gun
laws are based on racism 100 true now
they know much more about that topic
than I do so it's great for me to be
around them and kind of learn uh their
origin story and learn how they came to
be part of uh you know the self-defense
culture and the gun rights movement and
so that to me is just a benefit like
that's the best part we've we went to
ex-cal a couple weeks ago when Luke was
still here yep you ever hear of them
there it's like it's a really fantastic
shooting range in Virginia and I'm just
I'm you know we're in the range and
there's you know people of all different
races I see a couple black guys are
shooting some Mexican guys the guys
right to our right are Arabic of some
sort and I was like look at everybody
coming together laughing and smiling and
they they watched uh you know the full
auto and they're all laughing and
smiling and then one of the guys he's
like an Arabic accent he's like he's
watching one of our people hang out with
us is firing a suppressed uh fn57 or
something like that and he's like oh
that's so cool I'm like I know yeah it's
really cool and we're like a high five
and see that that's where everybody
comes together culture building I worked
with a guy um runs a group called guns
for everyone and and he's of Mexican
descent and one of his big things is
that he he prints his newsletter in
Spanish and his aim is to try to build
gun culture in Mexico where it literally
doesn't exist I mean you just can't get
a gun there so the culture doesn't exist
but he sees that as a gap that that he
can Bridge like that's that's his Niche
that's where he can provide value that
other people aren't and and it's only to
the benefit of of all of us I remember
on Twitter I love this uh this one story
someone tweeted something like Tim Poole
wants to take wants to give all the
crazy right-wing nut jobs guns but once
you know black people not to have them
and I was like what the hell are you
talking about I think every black
panther should be marked watching down
the street trapped with a you know
sidearm and an AR-15 because it's their
right to do so and it was like some
Lefty anti the guy he's responded he
responded with based and I'm like why
would you assume I think they shouldn't
have guns the the what is it called the
nfac the not effing around Coalition
aside from those negligent discharges
yeah I mean that's that's a big problem
I think it's great they're marching
around with guns for sure I I have no
problem with that but the negligence is
the safety and is there a limit to the
amount of guns you can carry legally at
once no that's why no so you could have
like 30 pistols on you if you could have
like 30 hands or something yeah
constitutional care in West Virginia you
could carry two uh Barrett how many twos
on your back very heavy whatever
whatever you want to carry yeah good
workout carrying those things have there
been advancements in lightweight guns
lately
yeah I mean you know polymer technology
started in the 80s you know the Glock
was like the first brand to really start
well I actually let me backtrack you
know that actually the AR-15 and the M16
was the first uh weapon that really
started to use uh polymers and Plastics
so that was a bit and that was in the
mid 60s but it took a while there's a
lot of um tradition in the you know
people like steel and wood they see it
as real and what have you so
um over time now pretty much every
handgun in the five to seven hundred
dollar range is going to have a polymer
frame and a steel slide so yeah the
advancement in technology we're
developing better polymers we're
starting to use more carbon fiber things
to try to make barrels lighter in
particular like with high Precision
rifles the big problem is the barrels
are very thick and so there's a lot of
material in the barrel and and they tend
to be very front heavy so what they're
doing instead is using a steel liner
with a carbon fiber outer wrap and that
will provide the stiffness and the
accuracy without creating something that
that is uh to unwieldy what's that um
uh it's a fully auto m321 or something
like that what is it you know better
than I would
um I'm not sure minigun it's like a full
auto I saw a video M3 something I don't
know okay well I mean I know what a
minigun is I'm not I don't know there's
just a video of some like super high
powered full auto with Tracer rounds and
it just legitimately looks like lasers
it looks like Star Wars laser blasters
just ripping through a vehicle and
tearing it to shreds is this the M3
grease gun and usually I don't know no
that's that's old and usually you know
when they load
um the bells ammo usually the there's a
tracer every like fourth or fifth round
right so when you see the Tracer know
that there's like five or six other
rounds that you're not seeing uh behind
it so yeah the fire rates are incredible
on uh m134s m3429
maybe it's the m134 it was it was really
fast what's the m stand for
yeah just machine gun I mean it's like
you know it's just acronyms everything
in government is acronym so like most of
these weapons obviously developed for
military contracts so they got to come
up with a shorthand acronym for for it
somehow it indicates that it has been
machined well it I don't it every
company is different but in that case
the M might stand for machine yeah here
watch this video
I don't know if it's gonna be too loud
or something oh I just saw this what
yeah I thought that was a laser it looks
like Star Wars laser blasts ripping
through this car
this isn't the video I saw earlier but
it's a video that goes this yeah yeah
m134 six or eight barrels that are
rotating uh so
incredible right it's a buzzing yeah it
looks like a video game yeah it's like
laser it's like it's like
plasma blasts and Star Wars or something
haven't you ever heard you know that's
that's the uh the meme is Bert b-r-r-r-t
and that's that's the uh the A-10
Warthog you know they built an entire
plane around a gun they developed they
developed the gun first and then they
built a plane that they could put the
gun into like that's crazy what gun is
that the A-10 Warthog is the is the
plane it was developed as a tank killer
and so they developed uh General
Electric developed uh uh
autocannon they call it and so it's it's
actually shooting a 30 millimeter uh
round which is enormous and they're
coming I I can't remember the rate of
fire off the top of my head but
I think it'll deplete the entire
ammunition in something like 20 it only
has like 20 or 30 seconds of sustained
fire wow and it's tens of thousands of
rounds this is the uh so they just had
Thunderbolt too exactly yeah so they
just zoom in and they they fire for only
maybe half a second but that's you know
three 400 rounds one was this built uh I
don't know exactly when it was developed
in 1976 yeah the 70s so it was developed
as a tank killer so it's shooting a 30
millimeter round depleted uranium
typically and so they're just zipping
right through they fly in low they they
zip through the tanks and then they fly
out that's crazy depleted uranium
nuclear weapons by the way
yeah all right we're gonna go to Super
Chat so if you haven't already would you
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends and become a member at
timcast.com we're gonna have that live
members only portion of the show going
up around 10 10 on the front page of the
website you will see it Live members
only and then after that wraps it stays
in the archive forever so you can watch
it but smash that like button and we'll
read what you guys have to say I'm not
your buddy guy says it's a very black
pill when you realize the only question
is who will be running a technocratic
enslave enslavement with a social credit
system China or the US I think Ian
should run it I feel like it'd be nice
no I think it would be it would be very
brutal yeah it would be at first but
that's only because I'm freeing the
system so that you can run it yourself
yeah
all right Rook 0613 says I just wanted
to say that Scott Adams isn't wrong on
any level with the rise of BLM I agree
white people avoiding black people makes
perfect sense except when you realize
that black lives matter is the activist
level mostly white literally is it's a
whole bunch of white people marching
around burning down black neighborhoods
so
well I guess maybe then what they're
saying is true those white racist antifa
people should avoid the black
neighborhoods they're causing damage too
all right let's see
ready to rumble says Tim ran away from
black people in Chicago what do you mean
no I didn't when when did I do that I've
only ever been mugged by a white guy
like literally had two white guys and it
was funny the story as I was in um
Lincoln Park I think and two white guys
one guy was trailing they did it for
security and then a tall white guy tried
mugging me and then it turned out they
lived like I don't know five or six
blocks away from where I lived because
they go to other neighborhoods to rob
people the the criminals do
you know maybe because you left the city
you were running away but I think you're
an example of someone that goes where
you want as opposed to fleas from what
they don't like also should you stay
somewhere I ran away from the tolerant
like I ran from White leftists it's like
Tucker Carlson got accused of being
racist and he's like what that's
ridiculous it's white liberal women I'm
complaining about yeah like what are you
talking about
the problem with with people who are mad
about a race is it's like
why is the race the issue when there are
clear examples of people of that race
who are some of the smartest and best
people
in in the Freedom Movement I just don't
I don't understand why the race is the
component the communism is the component
it's divide and conquer man that's like
alien dialectic crap it's Communist
Manifesto yeah communism is bad to be at
odds you know so like if there is a
black guy who's a communist I'm not
gonna be like it's a black guy I would
say it's a communist communist if
there's a black guy who's pro-2a and
conservative and he's got an American
flag and he's he's waving it with
sunglasses I'd be like that that's a
based MF you know and if you feel in
racist just stare at eyeballs spend some
time spend the next couple years staring
at eyeballs look at people look at their
eyeballs you realize we're brain stem
creatures we're the skin came afterwards
we're all basically the same kind of
unit
all right where are we at
what is this uh James
uh arenson says to counter your poll
would you support a chemical weapon
against China if it was Kept Secret
interesting question my answer is no
yeah chemical weapons that's a really
bad idea yeah I must say no I'm not your
buddy guy says I'd go to war with China
if it guaranteed an end to World
economic Forum ideas it does not
guarantee that though it'll probably
make it worse to be honest with you yeah
they'll use the violence as an excuse to
implement more harsh lockdowns and then
most people will be too passive to do
anything about it if you have one world
power instead of two world powers then
and you have to think critically like if
they say it'll end whatever don't
believe them it's not a guarantee I
think that's that's the problem with war
we we have all these false promises of
what it'll do and they're mostly wrong
and there's no way they could deliver
them yeah World War one they were like
it's going to be over by Christmas that
was a big part of going to war for the
British then you know four years later
elahad says War doesn't determine who's
right only who's left
yep
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim I say no
to war maybe China did release the virus
but it but it was the US government and
Democrats that instituted lockdowns
mandates and hate for us
there you go
Maureen McKay says Ukraine war no poll
I mean I don't think anybody supports
going to war in Ukraine
except for like Black Rock what do you
think we do first go to war in Ukraine
versus Russia or go to War in China
we're in war in Ukraine but like do you
think we'll focus there or do you think
we would wait until that conflict
resolves and then go to war with China
I don't see how I I mean I don't see how
we can do to Ukraine to be honest with
you so I don't see how we could do too I
mean they're already talking about huge
shortages
um in you know the availability of of
things like weapons in particular I mean
like ammunition right now it's large
caliber but it small caliber is being
affected too I'm already hearing um
about European primer manufacturers that
are starting to hold back their supply
because they they know that there's
money to be made in Ukraine Colt
zipriani says my girlfriend was adamant
that she never wanted kids until the day
she got off birth control now she is
begging for them interesting what
messing with a person's hormones can do
to their thoughts birth controls poison
you shouldn't take it yeah well there
are certain circumstances where it
actually is medication for people who
have like hormonal problems that's I
mean but like the idea of the the mass
medication of a society where they're
just like take a drug for no reason
without without any real reason and I
know that there are a lot of teen girls
who are told oh yeah you should take it
you've got hormonal issues your hormones
haven't leveled out and they put you on
birth control but the issue is then you
never address the hormonal issue right
there it taking birth control doesn't
reset your hormones but you come off
birth control you still have issues I
think the problem is that people go on
birth control and don't think about the
alternative of exploring because it's
simpler for gynecologists to prescribe
birth control than to do a lot of
testing I'm saying that birth control is
a literal medication that doctors over
prescribe there are certain
circumstances where any medication can
be properly prescribed sure but what
we're seeing now a lot of is like 16
year old girls go to the doctor and
they're like why don't you go on birth
control for no reason well and then it's
years and years later when there are
consequences right that's the thing but
they're they're treated like aspirin or
Tylenol or something when um you know
and your brain chemistry permanent
hormonal problems because of you know
all kinds of things yeah like uh ovarian
damage there's there's uh I'm not going
to get into the specifics of certain you
know medical problems but there's like
cystic stuff yeah and there you have to
be on it forever yeah but then there are
like the over the majority of what we're
seeing is just like every single person
is being told to go on hormonal drugs
yeah there's always case for medication
but I just think that we aren't
talking about the consequence
Consequence the right choice for your
body you should be able to know why not
just that this is the easiest solution
that you'll avoid you know more minoring
convenes is that perhaps your doctor
should Explore More seriously with you
Tech Rue 2024 says China admitted it was
an accidental lab leak when they
suggested Someone caught it from
something they ate Saving Face is an
element of Chinese culture where they
admit they screwed up by making a lame
excuse and everyone is expected to shake
their head sadly and drop the subject
like uh with Fukushima when they kept
saying everything's fine everything's
fine don't worry and the disaster is
getting worse and worse and worse and
then you know in the US we're really
frustrated like just admit it's not so
we can fix it but they have honor
culture so it's they have to keep saying
everything's fine even when it's not
yep yeah well you know this is what
happens
comrade Nikolai says hello everyone what
I think would be better is Rally our
allies together and force China to
cancel our national debt that's a
reasonable deal when you consider our
hundreds of dead grandparents in the
lockdowns oh that would be really upset
upset about that
Jeremy Herman Hernan says Second
Amendment for the whole world says the
ammo salesman LOL
that's me good for business I'd like to
think I'm more than that but
did you say before you don't sell to you
don't sell it to the military you don't
sell the cops correct do you mean like
you don't sell to the department
individual cop walked in off duty and
wanted a gun we have no problem selling
to individual police officers but we
stopped selling to police departments
and the reason for that is the Novi
Police Department came into my business
and uh wrote a report that resulted in
us getting fined by the health
department for not wearing masks in our
own building during the coveted
craziness and at that minute I just said
I'm done with this you know it's obvious
if it wasn't obvious before it's obvious
to me now and it should be obvious to
all gun owners that collectively as a
you know again not to like put labels on
on groups but
um I I try to live my life by like the
80 20 rule so the bottom line is 80 of
police officers are there to work a job
and so uh whether it's enforcing
mask mandates or enforcing gun
confiscation probably 80 percent of
people are going to just do what their
boss tells them to do and I just found
that to be an untenable situation and so
you know it wasn't a big part of our
sales anyway maybe it was 10 at the time
but uh I could see the shift and I I'll
be honest with you I most of the
individual police officers I work with
agree with me uh on it 100 so
all right Alaska pants says Liberia
failed right and wasn't it some kind of
version of the US Republic which was
artificially installed yes it was also
surrounded by a bunch of non-us
republic-based countries which
immediately started destroying and
exploiting it you can't solving a
problem of you know crime and these
issues that like Liberia faced is
you've got an entire continent of
Warring tribes and different factions as
it is a massive amount of power and
influence over specific areas that you
can't just come in and sound like a
small colony to be like okay you're good
we gave you the documents because it
takes only like a couple decades for
outside influences to come in and start
ripping apart those resources
so it's difficult to say the least you
know I'm not going to pretend to have to
have all of the answers but uh there are
there are you know there's there's funny
memes about like roads in Kenya
everything's beautiful the streets are
beautiful there's like some of the most
prominent Tech Development Centers there
I think it's called the ihub it's been a
long time since I talked to people from
there so you can take the best part of
an of like Liberia and then compare to
like the worst part of America and make
America look really really bad the the
real question is function of government
corruption levels crime levels you know
in in the bigger picture which is
ultimately where polls do come in we're
trying to extrapolate data from you
can't literally ask every single person
in the country it's impossible so we do
our best to try and figure out what is
causing these problems and uh I think
the answer is well
the one thing I find funny about people
who you know say would say that race
plays a huge comp is a huge component in
all of this as opposed to like ideology
I'm wondering why it is that it is
predominantly white Europeans that are
opening up their borders and allowing
people literally to walk into their
country and just start
you know causing the problems these
people are claiming right so in Japan
Japan's outright like closed borders
hard immigration and then it turns out
to be mostly white people who are like
we're Multicultural and everyone can
come here and do whatever they want and
that's other white people complaining
about the fact that white people are
doing it and I'm like does that mean
that white people have a very serious
submission problem and they're very a
weak and ineffectual people incapable of
defending their themselves no that's
ridiculous it means there's a corrupt
political ideology of Communism that's
destroying things I don't blame white
people for the white liberals I blame
white liberals
all right all right
here we go I'm not your buddy guy says
Will Ferrell as George Bush was funnier
for opening
yeah Woody Harrelson's opening was like
rambly and like it wasn't that good
until he made that political point that
was kind of funny you know I don't know
if I said before but he did play Biden
on on several SNL sketches so I find it
ironic that he's the one who's now like
making this point about the cartels and
drugs like there's there's something
there
all right yeah but Trump says Tim you
missed something about South Korea
surgeries it's actually weird if you
don't have surgery of some sort it's the
current plastic surgical surgical place
in the world yeah it's kind of crazy
that North Korea goes you know
starvation
hardcore like authoritarian and then
South Korea goes full on capitalist
plastic surgery for everybody it's like
an experiment almost and it's not just
uh plastic surgery they're the they're
one of the top Beauty Industries so any
kind of treatment that you want for your
skin or for your hair whatever else
South Korea is a leader in that field so
they have they are now X like if you
know anyone who does like K Beauty they
get special moisturizer or else like
they're exporting this industry that
they have cultivated and developed to
everywhere else in the world is it
technocratic in that are they like
turning to cyborgs more there than other
countries I don't know what are their
implant statuses are like yeah that's a
good question though I think that when
it comes to like neural link there's
going to be some countries like I bet
China neural links in two seconds oh my
gosh with the government yep right
they're going to be like your social
credit score drops by 300 points unless
you get neural link they're all gonna go
okay in the book and it's for your good
because when we change the law you'll
know right away what got changed you'll
know what law is not to break well down
you won't be able to break the law if
you ever try to your hands and body will
become your body becomes paralyzed right
yes your body will be collected you'll
be like some guy will get really angry
and I'll be walking up to and it'll be
like you kicked my dog and then he'll
raise a fist and then just freeze in
place imagine white white jumpsuits will
get out of the van and pull them in put
them in the van and drive off no they
don't need to
people who are on the verge of guys
about to like throw a wrap around the
ground and he just stops and freezes
their timeouts and then you calm down
yeah like you freeze for like 10 seconds
and then they stop and they hold it they
look around and they walk over to the
garbage and put it in on the TV a big
thing appears showing your picture and
being like tried to litter you could get
people to drop to their knees that's an
easy thing to do to their brain and then
just to face the Imperial Palace on
their knees and just bow yeah
the guy who like tries to litter is like
feeling pain right like through your
neural link to like get you to stop
doing it they're like a shock collar I
can't remember who was saying this but
they said what what the real scary thing
is that I think it was Phil maybe it was
Phil saying this that when you get Nora
link it'll do the tiniest bit of
dopamine when you do something they want
and it'll give you a negative reaction
tiny tiny bit and so over time it just
feels good doing what the machine tells
you to do but then there'll be
situations you'll be you'll be exactly
what social media apps no one needs to
tell you no one will need to tell you
not to litter you'll just start doing it
because you'll get a dopamine hit every
time you throw your garbage in the
garbage can and then there will be
situations where you're supposed to
litter like rarely you know like
whatever you're under command to do it
or something and it'll it'll hurt you'll
be like why or what you'll try to throw
in the trash but it'll hurt this time
and you'll be why is the thing that
feels good hurting I'm confused or what
if you get like roving bands of people
who really want another dopamine hit so
they're constantly finding places to
clean up so they can get like 100 hits
and then like you know that'll happen
that's legit what's going to be there's
going to be people like picking up
pulling dirt out of the ground and
throwing it in garbage cans because
their neural link breaks and they're
getting a dopamine hit from picking it
up because their brain thinks this is
garbage something's going in the trash
there's going to be groups of people who
are going to be like scratching and
getting that high and they're gonna be
like I need that Hitman and the
government's going to be like we need
this house built and they're going to be
like I'll build it and as they're
building like it feels so good to build
oh man just doing the work for free
yeah it's going to be terrifying I don't
like this at all get the neural link
it'll feel good yeah dopa means free
like fresh water and air like but it'll
feel good what's the problem right you
will be think about this what's what's
better for somebody sleeping on the
streets of LA covered in you know
garbage and and and doing drugs and then
dying or that person building houses and
doing construction
dopamine is not free because you need to
eat so you do need to acquire and
consume to get dopamine so if you could
do it in other ways that'd be
terrifying Probot says Scott was right
not all lions attack humans but if you
see a pack of them you avoid them you
don't stop to see which are tame that's
funny because uh Daryl Davis pointed out
that most serial killers tend to be
white and also black serial killer you
don't mean if you see a white person
assume they're a serial killer and also
don't compare humans to wild animals
dude that's the step towards what Hitler
did don't do that this uh that Meme
about not a lion's attack originated I'm
pretty sure with feminists who said not
all M Ms are if you have a bowl of M Ms
and 10 of them are poisoned not all M
M's right take a handful why don't you
and it's just like that's the stupidest
idea ever like
feminists were doing the Not all men
thing and they were like when people
were saying not all men are bad they
were like 10 you know 10 of the Skittles
are poisoned will you take a handful
that's right not all men that's what
we're saying and it's like that Meme has
been used to justify everything pretty
much everything blaming everybody other
than their garbage ideology I'll put it
this way
if I saw you talk about lions right
Lions not all lions attack humans if I
saw a group of black dudes waving proud
boys flags and wearing the proud boys
shirts I would and then I saw on the
other side a bunch of people with antifa
flags I would choose the side with the
black people for sure because the
ideology is the real issue if I was
walking down the street in Chicago and I
saw a bunch of black men wearing nice
business suits and carrying briefcases
and talking on their cell phones I'd be
like whatever and then if I saw a bunch
of white dudes with with guns baggy
pants and like prison tattoos or
something I'd probably be like well I
know it I honestly I'd probably just
walk past them whatever but like which
one are you gonna make a negative
assumption about it's not the race
that's the issue it's if a dude's waving
a Gadsden flag I don't care what his
race is I'm like oh based you know
Gadsden flag was flying an anti the flag
I don't care what his race is he's a
communist I think it only matters that
like fundamentally you don't want to
live next to someone who thinks that
your existence is bad and that's right
across all Races right and so if Scout
Adam's solution is to move away like
fine have a good time time if my
solution is to get to know my neighbors
and know them on a better level than
like also acceptable but if I had a
neighbor that thought I was bad I would
rather engage with them and get to know
them and override that preconception
then but what if you can't what if they
just always think you're bad because
my life what do you do what if they just
I'll let you know no reason if it
happens I'll let you know I've never had
that happen I mean you should have to
move but like this is the the thing that
Scott Adams coming up against right like
if he doesn't want to have to figure out
which which quarter which one in four of
these people think that he is
fundamentally not acceptable the way he
is then yeah okay move but deciding not
to engage that's cowardice Bretton
Bretton maybe says watch scat us watch
skip Scott Adams podcast from this past
week and his interview with hotep Jesus
before weighing in on this one Scott
knew this would happen before he made
the statements in question I 100 believe
that he did he he made statements about
it people had tweeted about it he said
he knew be canceled he knews would
happen he was going to say it or
whatever
yeah and his stuff is coming out of
publication but it's still available
online his podcast and stuff I mean
that's what I think people who know
they're going to get canceled end up
doing they just yeah offshore places to
go to Brado Jacko says bring on Scott
Adams and officer Tatum to discuss I
would love to I actually think that
would be a better thing for the culture
War podcast
where it's like a long-form conversation
specifically on this one issue as
opposed to like topical news of the
night yeah that'd be cool
yep fantastic Scott yeah do that and
then stick around for a Friday night IRL
did you do that dude yeah it's cool that
you have like two different ways to do
that now because not everyone is you can
talk about the news but not everyone is
in that format right
yep all right let's see what we got
where are we at
um
Mr grizzly bear says Ian doesn't seem to
understand how polls are supposed to
work yes Mr grizzly bear I try
explaining to him every single time we
talk about polls but I don't think he
cares I know how media manipulation is
supposed to work now I'm you see nice
now he's playing a semantic game to try
and they argue against what we're
actually talking about classes to
brainwash people into thinking that it's
that they when they say that it works
what do you mean because when people say
that vaccines work what do you mean does
that mean that
they stop the spread or does that mean
that they're just doing what they're
supposed to do uh working is a very
strange term so yeah the polls layout
info in the way that the poll is built
to lay out the info for sure but is that
value extrapolatable to the masses
that's my argument it's not I agree I
mean if if you're if you're pulling an
object an objective data point how many
people own a red car right that's right
but when you're doing like qualitative
you know how do you feel about white
people how do you feel about black
people I think that's where it gets
sticky that's where data can be easily
manipulated by starting with an answer
in mind and then developing questions or
going to a specific group of people
going to the respondents that you know
you go to the like County Meetup of red
cars and everyone's like yes we have a
red car and you conclude everyone in
America has a red car obviously that's a
terrible base set of data the real Hydro
says I have a clip of Ian saying that
when he was in Food Service he said that
when people of color came in to eat he
never expected them to tip because they
are poor oh I saw that Super Chat people
would tell me that to expect them not to
tip and so I would think you're a racist
and I'm I don't care if they tip me or
not I'm giving them the same quality of
uh service and that's what I would do
and there would be times that I would
get low tips from large families of
black people and there would be times I
would get low tips from large crowds of
white people and I never stopped giving
my best service
pull up the thing and tweet it out if
you really believe I said something for
that because if I did I wanna I wanna
acknowledge it
all right we'll see it on Twitter if you
said it American Gun chick says 90 of
gun 98 of gun manufacturers and
companies only care enough about two-way
to keep themselves in business I'll talk
little action Phoenix ammo is one of the
good guys in the fight thanks for being
so supportive of the 2A community
well thank you I appreciate that yeah I
mean I would say most gun companies are
part of that you know military
industrial complex in the sense that
their customers are really government
and law enforcement and so for us our
customer base is 100 percent
individual U.S citizens you know the
people who the second amendment was
written for and that's the big
difference that's that's what we've
always tried to keep in mind
all right let's see peace in Valhalla
says Tim you understand that genders
have Tendencies for example women are
women vote a certain way but when it
comes to race Scott Adams is crazy women
vote a certain way unless they're
married they would a different way it's
almost like the environmental factors
play a larger role on their politics
that's that's the point I'm making so I
said earlier in my video on Scott Adams
I do believe that there's a combination
of nature versus nurture and the people
who tried arguing that race plays no
role in physical characteristics like
they're just wrong but I believe that uh
nurture plays an outsized role Society
will have a bigger role on whether a
person behaves or does certain things as
opposed to the family or genetics that
they have in the long run I think what
I'm trying to say is humans of all
different races are are substantially
more similar
in that social functions will have a
larger impact on them regardless of
their race that being said people in
Sweden tend to be taller than people in
Thailand that's literal reality that's
going to have an impact on whether or
not people in Thailand can play
professional basketball in the United
States versus people from Sweden because
people in Sweden are more likely because
they're much taller and then you
actually have in the United States I
think what is it like um
uh what what is the percentage of the
NBA that's that's black it's like 70
something percent
I'll check them out for whatever reason
you know it's definitely a majority if
not a super majority I mean there is a
racial like there's a racial correlation
for whatever reason that is it that is a
fact you know I am not discounting the
fact that people from different have
people with different genetics will have
different things about them yeah it is
according to uh Alexa answers Alexa stop
uh dot amazon.com it's 74 74 what did I
say 70 yeah I was thinking it was 70 74
but I was like I didn't know for sure
that was in 2015. grouping 23.3 white
1.8 Latino and 0.2 percent Asian but
that was eight years ago but I I I there
was a
these two scientists
men and a woman and he believed that
intelligence could be like trained and
ingrained in a person and so then he
writes a letter to This Woman This is a
story right on the internet maybe it's
not true he writes a letter to this
woman and he's like hey I've I I'm
pretty confident I can raise children to
be genius level intellect so they have
kids and then all of their daughters are
like chess Grand Masters like Champions
or whatever and then someone said yeah
but you need to raise other people's
kids and other races and he's like I'm
an old man I'm not doing that
because people are arguing they're our
kids and you're a genius they're for
your kids are geniuses and I'm kind of
like I don't know man I think if you
take if you take uh a Nobel Prize winner
this newborn baby and drop them off in
Somalia he's gonna end up not being too
like healthy he'll be more likely be
malnourished there's Civil War there's
conflict there's crisis you put him in a
very wealthy pristine area where he's
getting access to nutrients and food and
all you know all the best education and
he's gonna it that's that's kind of a
bigger impact on anything else nutrition
so nutrition I think is the number one
thing that if you take any person of any
racial background and you give them
garbage food to eat yeah Plastics and
other nasty trash they're they're they
will not function properly affects the
development of your brain yeah and
everything else your muscles your height
like it's just obvious come on take a 12
year old kid and stop feeding him and
then he's going to be short for the rest
of his life that that's North Korea in
North Korea they're all shorter because
they don't have enough food their bodies
literally really can't grow girls with
serious anorexia show signs of like
cognitive uh deterioration because
they're not they're starving themselves
yeah does that cycle that into more
anorexia it it creates more uh
anxiety and different things like that
but it's ultimately extremely dangerous
yeah this is cool Brew Crew says with
the A10 you could only shoot it for a
maximum of like three seconds otherwise
The Recoil drops the air speed too much
to sustain lift yeah
yeah
so much that it affects the they had to
calibrate that into the uh the computers
that control the wow otherwise it would
fall yeah yeah and it affects you know
how unless they fire backwards that's
right they gotta fire from the back then
it'll go faster
that's actually really cool the the
plane is uh no propellers it's a
actually it's a mini gun in the back
that uses a recoil to fly
constant fire recoil to fly that's a
ridiculous way to do it all right let's
uh we'll grab one more here what do we
got
Probot says my point was about inner
city culture more than a race but until
minorities stop their racism I don't
care the left keeps using our morals
against us I'm ready to get into the mud
yep my point is about inner city culture
more than race uh I can tell you this
man where I grew up culture more than a
race on everything uh gangs came gangs
uh member gang members came in all
different sizes and colors so it really
was about the culture that was around
everybody
so with that being said would you kindly
smash the like button subscribe to this
channel share this show with your
friends and become a member over at
timcast.com go to timcast.com click join
us and in about 10 minutes on the front
page you will see the uncensored live
version of the show popping up I don't
think we have the chat stuff set up just
yet but there will be a live chat system
soon for the time being it's just our
typical members only show not family
friendly uncensored conversations and
we'll carry in the conversation from
there so smash that like button again
you can follow the show at timcast IRL
you can follow me personally at timcast
and I strongly encourage you to check
out the culture War podcast with Tim
pool on Apple and Spotify and all
podcast platforms first episode was
Friday I sat down with Ali London he is
a British man who lived in Seoul Korea
and was a transgender Korean woman and
actually got the surgeries and
everything and recently when the past
six or so months started
de-transitioning and talking about
identity issues and crisis and what's
what's happening we're gonna have a
musician on affected by
covid mandates we've got some other
large cultural personalities celebrities
and and um
political figures that are going to be
joining the culture War podcast Fridays
at 1pm at youtube.com timcast and uh
we'll just I'll leave it there Justin
you wanna shout anything out
uh yeah thanks for having me um one
thing I want to say real quick is we are
trying to raise money for firearms
policy coalition to fight a lot of these
uh anti-gun laws that they're trying to
pass here in Michigan as well as around
the country so
um if you guys want to head to our
website phoenixamo.com we have these uh
gun-free zone stickers five dollars from
every one of these stickers is going to
go directly to Firearms policy Coalition
it reads gun-free zone you are entering
an unprotected environment in the event
of an active shooter you are on your own
we feel like this is what gun-free zone
signs should actually look like because
that's the reality of what you're
walking into so we're encouraging people
to stick these uh wherever they think
they should stick them and uh legally
yeah legally of course
so
um that's it that's Phoenix
f-e-n-f-e-n-i-x ammo.com uh it's also
Phoenix ammunition Twitter still blocks
our our main URL
phoenixamo.com so you can type the long
one phoenixammunition.com same place and
you're on Twitter or anything like that
yeah we're on Twitter at Phoenix
ammunition
um that's where you can find us cool
I'm Hannah Claire brimlow I'm a writer
for timcast.com thanks so much for
having me on tonight uh you can follow
at timcast news on Twitter and Instagram
it's the best you can see work for me
and all of our other journalists if you
want to follow me personally you can
find me on Instagram at hannahclair.b
and you can follow me on Twitter at HC
bromelo thanks so much I am Ian cross
and follow me Ian crossland.net and
subscribe to me on YouTube if you'd like
to follow me at Ian Crossland anywhere
else at Ian Crossland I'll see you guys
later I am at surge.com I am just
currently getting this new mixer to work
guys so if it wasn't perfect in audio it
will be soon uh yeah what's up everyone
we will see you all over at timcast.com
in about 10 minutes for the members only
show thanks for hanging up